it is a beautiful Friday afternoon
beautiful day thank you guys for being
here it's Friday it's after dark joined
by the beautiful Ela and the Dior bucket
hat okay
are you all deodored out the Fisher too
okay it's this vintage uh jador Dior did
you get it from the vintage lady from
eBay oh eBay that's what's up there
oh it was expensive I thought it
wouldn't be well what how about you
guess
you start this shirt yes
I mean under 50.
seriously I
mean it's vintage
[Music]
it's kind of like trendy right now
vintage Dior this specific statement the
grindstones
okay well you putting words in my mouth
in French I don't know nothing about
Dior vintage Dior is important well I'm
afraid to ask and now that it's not
under 50. is it under 100 no oh my God
what the
so this is still hot because I don't
know sometimes just used designer
clothes is like yeah not that expensive
right but not in this case no is it
under 250
what I'm rude how are you spending our
money
holy but how much was that shirt
and everything so it this is accumulated
value
I don't actually know it probably was
more
it's just a it's just a t-shirt really
at the end of the day let me feel the
fact it's a piece of History
okay
man it doesn't
feels like our Classics material
which people can pick up for what like
15 bucks yeah oh yeah
because it's a steal Dan wants to guess
go ahead Dan yes
I bet that shirt was like 800 no no but
thank you that makes me feel better
yeah it was like 350. oh my God we're
gonna go we're gonna go buying all these
vintage designer t-shirts it sounds like
it's collecting value though yes it's
kind of an investment but don't wear it
then but you got to put it in the attic
and wrap it in you gotta you gotta air
suck it or whatever vacuum seal it yeah
right like my dad used to have Peewee
Playhouse like 10 of them in the Attic
oh rip to the goat dude
and then I don't think he made any money
from those
actually you might know
maybe smash that button uh thank you
today to hexclad for sponsoring guys I
love our sponsors dearly and I love hex
Cloud so much so thank you to them
okay we got a great show here today for
which is different for us we have um
we've tried FaZe rugs gummy Challenge
and it was
so I want to try it
so you want to try one right now well
when we do this okay we have five left
so it's pretty good it'll go around so
we're gonna try one of his can
do's and then we're gonna go to the
world of sour candies and just see like
I bet you like half of these are are
even more are more sour yeah so we're
gonna do it now is the tier list about
flavor or sourness well we were debating
that before the show I mean what's your
input I feel like it has to be a balance
of the two well not just pure because
I'm just trying to show I want to show
how this product is right and so if
we do I don't think it was good even on
the metric of a candy though
I think it should just be on sour okay
just how sour sour and then the uh
the final the finale here Sam went in
the laboratory and has created a
Frankenstein's monster of sour
suicide sour Kamikaze damn you want to
supplement that with some info
oh you're muted
still muted
hold on one sec Sam is beautiful
technical difficulty
poopy
he took his
he took his cheese balls today I have to
give him medicine
anti-nausea and uh Omeprazole which is
heartburn
to lower his
his stomach acids yeah he's puking it
out a lot and he stopped puking since
we've been there yes yeah he has
uh the vet is coming today by the way at
like two or something so
Alina what if the vet comes I just want
to know if if I can't step away
I just want to know if Shredder is like
underweight
how's his how's he look is he hydrated
you know what I mean right and then
she's gonna come out and talk to her
right if I'm just saying if I can't okay
just just that's the information I want
because he I noticed I I don't know if
I'm
if it is happening or not it seems to me
that he might be eating less oh so I
wanted to make sure he's not losing
weight if she can tell me that okay yeah
I'll let you know when she's here you
guys see how Fredo
yeah I'm over on okay go go ahead so
yeah I made homemade warheads and I
tried to kick him up a notch so we'll
see
now did you
what was the material did you use these
to make it or did you no I'm no I made
them from scratch oh so we'll see I
watched a lot of Warhead Factory videos
a lot of Claire staffit's videos so oh
we might have to package that the H3
sour challenge huh the real one
face rug challenge yeah
how do you make sour Sam what is that
flavor
it's uh a combination of acids but
mostly citric acid oh just super
concentrated lemon juice yeah pretty
much I mean that's how they just extract
it from lemons mostly so
yeah I'm interested to see if uh you'll
think it's worse than Warhead
well this is very exciting because we
have the Extreme Sour WarHeads so this
is not this is real right here boy
anyway that's coming up
um we also have
um
xqc literally said he's gonna sue me
because I called him a Content Thief
yeah last night I was
um I was actually doing a photo shoot
and while we were all having fun all of
a sudden I see you talking about another
lawsuit I was like what he also made fun
of my Tourette's which you know I was
like
again I don't really care but it's
always so pathetic it's always a loser
move it doesn't make me feel bad or
anything yeah it's just a loser move
like here it is if you ever see a video
like that on YouTube and this this is
the quality of react you can get
from your boy xqc it is most likely from
a fan channel that took a straight bod
rip and posted it on YouTube and is
monetizing it themselves it's not it's
not touching me in any capacity
and can I be honest with you there will
be a time in my opinion it's gonna
there'll be some legal Hammer that will
come down on streamers and there will be
a time you know Jack no chat no chat bro
come on it's like time to grow up a
little bit more dude people were gonna
start I mean me having ticks is not like
a response to what I'm saying I don't
know if he thinks it is I think he
thinks that that's our own
he's incoherent most of the time but he
actually messaged me he wants to debate
so I guess we're gonna have a call on
Monday where he's gonna try to explain
to me how sitting quietly and watching
on three hour documentary isn't content
theft I look forward to hearing that
what is that what he's doing I mean I'm
exaggerating but yeah basically that's
the criticism he's getting hey Gabe
what's up
Uncle Gabe
it's my boy my uncle
all right
giving Donna
Gabe is having a hard time out there
it's a hot sunny day in L.A boy
there's just no love for Gabe out there
keep flipping Gabe it's gonna work I
love the flipping
can you hear us Gabe
[Music]
you know Gabe is usually pretty tech
savvy this is this is unusual for him
but it is fun
[Music]
that
right there you go
there he is
okay baby baby you keep flipping it or
is that like what's happening
is that you
yeah
wait why do you keep flipping it
this is like a new tick tock Trend wait
this is a whole new Dynamic this is a
whole new paradigm
yeah
baby uh it's flipped is what is this
triller
all right listen Gabe
I love you buddy
I think it's upset you have a good
weekend okay yeah we're doing the sour
challenge challenge Uncle Gabe everybody
hey guys
all right yeah baby yeah wore it baby
hell yeah
[Applause]
I just want to say it's Friday baby I'm
having technical difficulty on my phone
because it's connected to the car we're
on our way to San Diego and going to the
zoo
Gabe can you hear me damn can you hear
me
oh man
having a game
can you hear me
okay uh this is Shadow Gabe who has a
good internet connection
I'm Bizarro game I've come to take your
place I'm white claw Gabe I've come to
destroy okay you're good I've come to
supplant you
what's going on Uncle Gabe you will
never call in again because White Cloud
Gabe is taking over
[Laughter]
you will never
he's going to San Diego I'm going to
Santa Barbara
this is Bizarro white I'm going to the
zoo in Santa Barbara
oh you're back you good
oh no no no
I'm Bizarro Gabe I got a huge
sponsorship from White claw I live in a
giant mansion in Beverly Hills with my
white Claw Money
and look at you
you want to do a warhead for us
Warheads baby I just got it from the 99
cent store you got those for 99 cents
yeah
holy that's a good deal a buck 30
but
yeah these are the best
Buck 30
yeah
you didn't ask them about like why is
this a dollar Thirty it's 99 cents
I don't know it's because of the
inflation it's inflation
inflation's hitting the 99 cent store I
gotta add that to the title 99 cent
store plus inflation right
you want to hit one game or you're gonna
save them for the drive
I'll save some for the drop baby I'll
have one yeah let's do that yes yes all
right let's see how good you are show me
how oh what the f it's a whole bag of
them they're gummies though so I don't I
don't know how those ones hang up
compare
how do they taste
super sour but good night okay your sour
God look at you without hesitation no
problem he's gonna melt down
all right gabo have fun in San Diego say
hi to the animals for me yeah
we love them yeah baby
the baby
going to the zoo have you seen an
anteater they have an anteater
you remember yeah pissed on my ass on
the phone because my phone
technical difficulties I'm sorry about
that but no you're good anyway perfect
Friday baby oh I have a good one I put I
hope that ant eater puts his tongue up
my ass
and navigates my my intestines like an
ant hill baby because you've seen how
their tongue is like super long and it
can go up and down is perfect for eating
ass
yeah man baby
yeah share on my warheads and don't give
them Warheads though
that probably would kill them
yeah don't do that
okay
foreign
doing some tongue action on me I see I
see your game
that's how the snake does it oh yeah
oh lick my snake did you
well interest do you know snakes smell
from their tongue so that's also an
interesting connection yeah
all right cable have a good weekend okay
have fun at San Diego have a good one
Friday baby take care bye dude
that his uncle gave everybody the artist
formerly known as white claw gave we
don't talk about white claws anymore
they're scum and uh we don't we don't
with white claws just uncles
foreign
all right all right
all right all right all right all right
see you again all right all right all
right all right
what a guy he's a good guy what a guy he
always finds the time to call in I
appreciate that
um
so what were we saying yeah we've got
all kinds of stuff we got the xuc
Apparently Kai sanat who's like the
number one twitch streamer just right
now we were talking about it before you
got in he's just caused like a massive
riot and times are in a Union Square
a riot I don't know if it's all right
but it looked like it was bordering on
one
what like a meet up yeah he was doing
like a giveaway and it was like
he started running dude
started running him in his security
jumped up a hill and the girl he was
with didn't make it she got like eaten
by zombies dude they're picking her
bones right now
hold on rough
so we have footage of that yeah we do
so uh I guess we can watch that I mean
it's happening right now let's see so
here he is announcing is he showing it
all live
yeah well he went his camera fell on the
ground and then defeat that like
literally Blair Witch Project oh my God
so here he says be there kaisan at New
York City
or giveaway 14th Street Union Square
Park our question is did he get a how do
you do a giveaway with
these people just showing up in his
place they just show up
my question is did he get a permit
because if he didn't he's going to be
absolutely by the city of New
York
um
so here's the announcement I guess and
then
here is a tweet promoting the event okay
okay he's hyping it up God did oh that
that's a DJ Khaled thing he's back I
told you he's back he is having a moment
tell him to bring out the whole ocean
god dude
[Laughter]
God did huh
friend of the show DJ Cloud uh we live
right now on Twitch pull up ASAP okay
it's all happening
foreign
and then cut to ABC helicopter
New York City
Live Action News
yeah there was no permit for that then
there's no way that's what well the
police are there already but I guess
this is the aftermath there's trash
everywhere oh God yeah this is actual
live feed Union Square is not a place
you want to with because it's like
a main one right now
if you scroll down the article they have
the full video
I mean so Union Square if you don't know
is a major Hub there's like tons of uh
major
um uh subway station lots of Tourism
stores
very popular spot so shutting that whole
place down including the surrounding
streets is quite psychotic
for the city that that that's not good
so here's ABC
where's the one of that I saw the uh
when it was first happening
yeah that's what I
where is it at the bottom
god dude which number uh oh I'm sorry no
I was in that uh article that you were
just at watching the live stream uh
number four
in the bottom of this that's what I just
opened
I don't think they would give anybody
apartment to do that oh yes so okay so
here's the live report
it was closed off because of
construction but look up online that's
what's happening on top of this song I
want to know what did it give away I
can't even count I was like a PS5
giveaway I think that's awesome this one
this one anybody correct me on that
money ps5s technical stuff yeah
no no no one he ran for his life
I'll tell you that clip
um while you came out here what you
expected to happen what did happen all
right my name is
in the article you can see when he pulls
up there's like people on his car if
that's his car or that's just a random
car not even this is still the aftermath
this is so insane
[Music]
um
let's see but you'll notice that the
streets are totally blocked off
or I mean the traffic I mean is just at
a dead stand no this is crazy then yeah
give away for the fence giveaway of what
was the understanding so from my
understanding PS5 this video y'all want
a PS5 I can do that
y'all don't need to shut down like the
biggest Metropolis in the city in the
country one of the biggest in the world
PCS
don't think they will actually give away
an actual PC because how is somebody
going to carry that so yeah that's what
I'm
going and get the P5 himself they have
to assume that you along with your
friends came out here thinking that you
would get some freebies is that correct
not that we're thinking but there's a
chance to because you know there's so
many people and there's only so much you
can give has anything happened is he
here um he's here right now yeah and
they were giving out but people are okay
here's the clip
uh here it is here it is thank you Cam
several others this is live wait okay
all these feeds are live so I think
that's what's confusing you you know we
don't skip to about 25 minutes oh I can
go back on this yeah okay great the
other one I couldn't so okay yeah yeah
look at this Gila we'll go back to the
beginning crowds were like merging in on
each other here's the helicopter
throwing bottles and buckets and it
looked like wait they're dropping the
face
this is January 6 bro this is switch TV
January 6th look at the chaos man
they're there
there's a Best Buy right there in the
Union Square they're gonna break that
place they want that PS5 through hell or
high water
I mean I guess uh great job social media
stars were out there
well we'll have to know I don't know
because his like whole production
everything seems pretty professional to
me I I'm leaning towards they probably
did get permission yeah no way I think
so too and it just got out of hand but
even if they did have permission I guess
I guess then that he's just like Paul
McCartney he's just the Beatles I don't
know what to say right but what was it
planned to look like where was the setup
was there any setup it looks like he had
some kind of seemed like there was
something there right that's some kind
of little fort here with some shoddy
yeah planning and bad like you know
crowd control and then here's the police
being attacked like what the are
y'all doing yeah where's my PS5 if you
guys get a nice single file line you
will get it you pig where's my PS5
[Laughter]
dude they're pissed bro
yo I was expl I was promising your Xbox
LIVE look at that oh my God God damn yo
this is like the last place I ever want
to be
um these are people getting like crushed
in there too yeah it's very dangerous so
this is what we saw live that's crazy
so many people I feel like I was seeing
like crowd control things mixed in
amongst the crowd I think it just got
overrun yeah there's a railing there's a
like a massive railing well what I don't
understand is see these are live streets
look at these cars this traffic is
gridlocked for hours oh boy Manhattan is
going to be for like the whole
day
this is like worse than when the
president comes to town
just a Bus full of people here
so I found that pretty funny pretty
interesting
um
oh here's his stream this is really
quite quite interesting so I guess yeah
they're inside of that little building
so you guys are right you probably did
have a permit huh he must have right no
this is inside the truck or like a car
they didn't expect it to be that crazy
oh so he's not in the center I think
he's that I think they got stopped in
the road so they had they like left the
car to go walk there but that was
obviously the mistake
then they got swarmed he got stuck in
his own gridlock yeah exactly that's I
and I think they were to walk there yeah
and it seems like oh what a nightmare
all right so check check this out dude
it's absolutely insane
[Music]
all right right he's asking where's the
park
all right
yo I can't have nobody bumping into my
book bag this time
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah everybody's got this forward now
they're running for their lives
a good thing he's got like the biggest
bodyguards I've ever seen yeah
that was smart
they're just running for their lives
dude look how look how worried they are
the bodyguards
yep he's starting to hear that boy now
they're jumping the wall booking it and
watch his girl tries to jump up
she's dead the camera hits the floor the
head feed ends
[Music]
straight up
they took the camera they're like we're
not getting a PS5 and taking the damn
camera yeah pure chaos and now he's
offline
wow and that was
I was one big disaster Jesus Christ oh
he did a story two minutes ago this is
good okay let's take a look here's an
update from Kai
he says
I love you guys to the fullest you guys
are amazing the love from home base is
real please be safe
you know what he's giving stand back and
stand back hey it's Trump on January 6th
I love you you're very special but
please you have to go home stand back
and stand back
he's not even saying go home you know
what I mean he's saying stand back and
stand by you're very special
very special we love you we love you
um the vet is here yeah maybe just grab
Shredder Lena
yeah before he knows what's going on
oh crazy well I hope anybody got too
seriously injured because that I hope
God that wow that would be awful yeah
that would be and I you know what I mean
my heart just goes out to the people
that really need that PS5
which is apparently a lot
oh yeah a lot of people need PS5
and then I had a hard time the rest of
the weekend
[Music]
um here's a the IRL stream or this is
his stream hey what is this there's a
Taco Bell ad
oh let's watch this man you Taco
Bell pay me yeah
okay whatever so that's happening right
now
twitch January 6 is happening
they were storming Best Buy in Union
Square August 4th we'll never forget
this hollow day
oh right there was a massive fight uh
breaking out when we were watching live
too yeah I wonder if we could I mean
probably it's somewhere in the
helicopter footage but yeah they were
all in the creek people were straight up
throwing punches on each other wow
there it is
so should we ever do a giveaway I was
just gonna say not to like toot my own
horn but I don't think if we did a fan
meet up people would start fighting and
attacking the police
I just don't think so yeah I don't know
it's New York it's uh
and they're his fan base is a bunch of
routers really hot it is what it is like
it's hot that's true yeah you know
murders go up when it's hot yeah the the
temperatures are boiling that's hot
that's hot
and then the cop come at you and you
just have to throw a bottle apparently
I get it it's just a knee-jerk reaction
when you see a cop you throw a bottom
all right so let's do some Goofs and
gaps at the top here
we'll get into the main stories we're
actually almost at 30 if you want to
knock that out or we could do one more
goof and then some I just want to say
Chad that says I have a PS5 and it's a
paperweight right now
oh come on oh dude what the I'm
dude I'm setting a riot to your home
we're storming that I'm gonna call
him by name reek I'm crawling in through
the windows now ghastly
oh here's a big one Rick Gastly said
something about chicken fried never mind
Rick astley's in the chat
but no the PS5 comment was from somebody
that didn't have the courage to put a
name in there give me your address
just kidding don't put your address
Jesus please don't do that all right
check this out big announcement for the
ad we have one sponsors it'll be fast
but Teddy fresh is announcing finally
some of you suspected but here it is
petty fresh X
Trixie Mattel
and look at this photo shoot fire
and also fire it's amazing and these
outfits the designs phenomenal
I'm so happy with it and I don't know if
I should ever refer to him as a he or a
she but when he's not in Dragon City and
when he's in drag it's a sheet okay yeah
so he was crushing it he was loving the
looks and it was so I wasn't there but
by all accounts the photo shoot was I
was there and it was amazing and
everybody loved everything just the
whole the whole photo shoot went so well
it was so fun oh yes it was just Good
Vibes only dude Sam made the best
I can't wait for you guys so crazy
The Collection came out amazing I saw
the pictures to come out
Trixie really loved all the pieces which
was just like the biggest like
accomplishment you know when you design
something it's like
if you ever watch Project Runway working
with a client is the hardest the hardest
challenge because you gotta like you
gotta make them happy and you gotta keep
your identity and the designs and
um that's kind of like how I see it when
we work on collabs
and Trixie
loved everything like seriously loved it
when I saw I saw her wearing some of the
pieces already Yes public yeah that was
really cool
thank you to the state of Texas by the
way for 50 gifted subscribe
for the State of Texas huh so this is
all very exciting it's coming out uh
August 24th yeah so actually we have
another
um release that's gonna come out before
but I
I couldn't hold on to these pictures
it's and to this secret so
we posted this it's a teaser but
um please be patient until I'm actually
the hype is pretty great I mean it has
84 000 likes before we talked about it
that's pretty great thank you guys for
your interest being excited about this
and thank you to Trixie who uh
you know
is working with us Legend and tati the
legend shot these
did great too
yeah so there it is that's very exciting
we're looking forward to that
well done illa not everybody uh thank
you I know we moved on from Kai but just
one more clip but Avery just sent me
it's actually Hassan's streams we're
gonna do one of these but
apparently this is Kai in this car when
he drove off and look at all the fan oh
my God
wait go back
off don't do this by the way this is
this is it don't do this okay hold on
get it off the screen
don't do that you guys that's that is
something that you should never ever
ever do
wow now that's sad
what's the deal with him he's seriously
like the Beatles do it it is death I
know he's popular but like oh he's like
right on the car popular wrong I'm well
proven wrong that's wrong yeah why is
the car going so fast when they know
there's like people attached to it
it's a fight for their life
well a little reckless a little white
little record a little reckless
um uh 10 donation from Victoria YouTuber
Kai sonnet has a giveaway in New York
City and it caused a riot live on most
news sources
Victoria
okay Victoria watching and not listening
breaking news
um
that was insane that clip on the bus
yeah that was wild
so what kind of content does it do
you know I haven't really watched but I
know people like him he's funny
apparently also I saw him get a hand job
once on live which is kind of oh that's
the same guy
I think he's alleging that he wasn't
getting a hand job but we all know that
yeah cheers
love ya
okay so let's thank our sponsor the
wonderful
hexclad who I have the pleasure of
partnering with I am absolutely in love
with this brand me too love you
I love you hexclad and listen what they
make manly is pots and pans they still
have other incredible kitchen items like
knives and cutting boards which are
great I have those too but they're known
for these incredible pants
these aren't just normal pans these are
super pans
let me show you what I'm talking about
Gordon Ramsay's gushing hexland's
industry-leading cookware doesn't just
stop with pans it's six piece pot set
will perfectly round out your cooking
collection from mashing the most amazing
potatoes to even tempering chocolate
what Gordon Ramsay is so bouncy if you
notice that it's like always bouncing
it's just it's got that much energy is
he just buzzing he's buzzing man I want
what he's on I mean he does a lot look
how he just bounces the man is just
leading cookware doesn't just stop
his tippy toes all the time you round
out your cooking collection from mashing
the most amazing potatoes to eat that's
just how excited he is xcloud.com
he definitely use code after dark yeah
well I don't care about the foodborne
show me the pants the food look good
ultimate durability right there's no
limit to what you can do it get creative
and Dazzle so it has this incredible
um
pattern that they've built in these
hexagons
and somehow they've created this pan
that's non-stick
and scratch proof you can literally use
a metal fork in it
I didn't know that no and it doesn't
scratch wow is that crazy pretty cool
and so you know if it's got everything
you would want or need in a pan
um
it's all I use now at home yeah I can't
wait for my mom to use it it's coming oh
that'll we should have her do a review
next review here's ela's mom guys
um let me go to their website so you can
get a better look at these gorgeous pans
[Music]
but um yeah I use it for
everything now using it for steaks I'm
using for pastas yeah
sauces sources here's the here it is all
different flavors different flavors
flavors
um here's their website check this out
look at that dude look at that it's it's
a revolution it really is I don't think
I've seen one person use this who wasn't
totally blown away I was using this
before
this is one of the brands where I'm like
I love this product I want to reach out
and see if they want to work together
sometimes that actually works and this
is one of those times
um
[Music]
it's it's I'll say the price point is
like expense pants are expensive they
are expensive and so I think the price
point is fair for what it it's more than
fair for what it is
but I remember the first time we bought
a set of pens like we gotta spend that
much 500 yeah but those were pans
even then because you want a pan if
you're gonna spend 200 on a pan right
you want it to last yeah this pan is
never going to betray you and it looks
Cooks
Tex Cloud all day every day baby
yeah
[Music]
yeah I got good news for you guys too
find your Forever cookware at hexclad
and get 10 off with the promo code after
Dark
go to hexclad.com after dark is there an
exclamation in the URL or no
oh it's very confusing you just need to
be like they're just excited you need to
be bouncing like Gordon you're not
bouncing enough yeah
once again go to hexcloud.com after Dark
Link is in the description guys 10 off
and listen if you're in the if you're in
the market for cookware I'm telling you
he's telling you you're gonna say thank
you Ethan I love my hex cloud
thank you guys thank you to x-clad
Funky Boy let's freaking go
hey
let's freaking go
okay it's Friday let's freaking go
[Music]
where's that music coming from so good
our boys at uh epidemic sound royalty
free thank you guys very much shout out
yeah those guys roll I think we just pay
like a monthly thing is that a month
yeah yeah oh yeah well worth it power
out
um
so did you hear we're nominated for a
streamy again oh yeah I did
of course we are I'm the ultimate price
never the bride always the bridesmaid
and so will this year be different what
do you guys okay so at first I was like
because they reached out to me way
earlier than usual to tell me I was
nominated and they were asking for put
it or for pictures and I was like oh
we're gonna win and by the way this is
like the sixth time like they gotta they
they you know what I mean and like
clearly if you look at the other shows
ours is better oh
obviously and so like you've got to stop
pretending and just give me the
award yeah yep I know I talk about
you guys all the time but like it's
bigger than that
and your integrity is on the line yep
and so I thought we were gonna win until
I saw this
they put together a Sizzle reel
of all the nominees look what they put
look what they put for me
check this out
I think he's a pathological
[Applause]
I do stupid shitty dumbass you know he
interviewed Joe Biden
God I hate him Thomas
stupid beautiful eyed those eyes
who are you how dare you have the eyes
that beautiful I think he's an asset we
were talking about this earlier today oh
yeah where did he come from
a three-letter agency FBI probably FBI
maybe has anyone ever asked those
questions yeah I would like to if you'd
have the if you have the balls to invite
me on his show yeah on purpose I'll show
you a purpose Jay Shetty to overthrow
the US government Maybe
you know uh
right I'm dying to see what Clips
but hold on so they asked you for Clips
did you no no they edited this they
asked for a picture okay to put on their
website okay
everyone welcome back to on purpose the
number one Health podcast in the world
thanks to each and every one of you it's
a rainy day out here in Los Angeles
[Music]
[Laughter]
those bro what the what the
that it's a rainy day
is that all you need to see what am I a
weatherman I am just shitty uh I'm the
number one podcast in the world I saved
the puppy's life this morning oh yeah
well what is this the Weather Channel I
mean I you know I it's like what the
how does that represent me
day out here in Los Angeles seriously
why did they do that you've also like
never sounded less like yourself a rainy
day in Los Angeles you're kind of like
saying it like ironic I was yes yeah and
so beginning there's no shot we're
winning after I saw that and then a few
people even get that's not fair no yeah
even bother to nominate us
but here is um so two podcasts get even
two appearances watch this and every one
of you it's a rainy day out here in Los
Angeles do you think you ever turned to
Blind Eye call her daddy that's her
second appearance yes and she got the
hero shot in the beginning
we don't know what episode it is ever
you've been saying 100 for about I think
7.85. at least there's like something
happening there and he wants you to wire
him a dollar and then Logan Paul
got two
okay unbelievable Logan Paul these
prolific scammer that's just not okay
look at that frame thank you everybody
so um I'm in Los Angeles I don't think
we're gonna win well I guess these guys
want to go so I'm going to send them
with fake Ethan
it's a rainy day but the reason I don't
want to want to go I would consider it
frankly but last year when Ian went with
fake Ethan they announced the winner
during the commercial break they the
people in the building didn't even know
who won the podcast award who
cares about podcasts Yeah well yeah
right so so who cares about the
streamies
not me
clearly a rainy day out here in Los
Angeles that's me
podcast the the weather guy why would
they pick that because they hate
me so somebody who had the theory that
pointed this out that um apparently that
clip is from the opening seconds of the
Tana podcast it's like literally like
the first five seconds yes it's uh in
the dock it's the next link okay yeah so
they just clicked some I think they
clicked a random episode and just took
the first like five seconds that's nice
I can tell somebody there's a is a big
fan of the show
let's take a look here part of Mikana
wants us to go and fully dress up
we could really like put us at a
table like 20 seats back it's
humiliating
but we could really stunt right then
they put your ass in the back you lost
there's really a back you know you look
better than this now
don't you want to kind of like show off
and be like hey losers no because
they're they're gonna put you at the
back of the bus and they're not
even going to acknowledge you it's it's
Ryan can you there's no reason in the
back were you stuck in the back yeah it
was sort of like a a big toilet bowl and
we were on the outer bowl with like six
moist criticals right they put him with
the moist you
eat us with all the moist critical
imposter I'm not I'm not doing that I
can't put myself through something like
that it's humiliating can we put it up
for a vote what does everybody think we
should do
they're not even gonna give us a table
this time we'll probably make us sit on
this on the steps behind the
it's a rainy day the floor Los Angeles
maybe maybe they'll give a standing
space
honestly it's a game you got to play the
game last year I tried no you didn't you
didn't you said you sent an impression
because we didn't lie to them if we show
up this time and we slay then next time
they're gonna be like we made a mistake
dude we need those people in the front
last time
I try to play the game with them and I
even was like I'm coming when they
invited me I said I am coming RSVP yes
to give them the opportunity to do the
right thing coming and year after year
these people they continue to do the
wrong thing
now I can't help them watch they're
going to give it to here's yeah this is
the H3 podcast according to the Streamys
hey everybody the number one weather
podcast in the world looking a little
rainy in San Diego today 59 degrees a
light rain clear up by night time go out
to Las Vegas nice sunny day 61 degrees
coming in here it's a rainy day out here
in Los Angeles welcome by the way
today's Street podcast oh God that's so
funny
so um I don't know I don't know you we
could put it up to a vote if you want
but I'm I'm still anti-streaming I think
you gotta play the game
you might as well just say you're going
because the audience is going to tell us
to go
but it shouldn't dude it needs to be
this they have no integrity
okay do a poll let's see if people want
us to go or not should should Ethan and
Ela
go to the streamies well also something
you guys don't consider is that it's
just going to be a room full of people
that I've spent years on
well Ian can you tell us what was it
like last time is it correct well
they they put the high rollers sort of
in their own section so
I don't know if they'll see you over
there so you may not have to even talk
to them like who who are we worried
about
no like Logan or when people like yeah
all those guys are right at the front so
you won't worry they'll put you in the
back so you don't have to come on dude
I'm gonna sit behind them I mean I'm a
grown ass man dude I'm a grown ass man I
can't show up and be humiliated like
that I won't recover
you know that kind of stuff has a
lasting effect on the ego
so we never saw Logan since that one
time right
since the car story yeah you guys heard
that by the way
I'm gonna punch you yeah I've never I
haven't seen him in person since that no
hmm
uh
okay I mean obviously everyone's gonna
say yes but yeah it's obvious I'm not
going to that
you guys don't understand it will ruin
the rest of my year
I went to the Streamys and they sat me
in the back and I ruined the rest of my
year I think you're overestimating it I
think you do well with people in person
oh definitely by by this podcast how
many like always exaggerating about
himself yeah come on to the show and you
guys always wind up being allies maybe
this is an opportunity
I think we need to have a rally outside
the streamies and storm them to if we
don't win we are going to
who's the vice president who's the
president of streamies we need to make
sure that he does not certify the vote
okay okay
otherwise if I don't win it's rigged let
me tell you that right now yeah I mean
it is it's rigged we love you and we
will storm the streamies if we must
they're gonna be great great cheesecake
you haven't stopped talking about that
cheesecake he loved that cheesecake I do
love cheesecake Chrissy Sherlock love
you by the way she says my dad watches
the Pod for the first time this weekend
loves you guys already big shout out to
the family
big daddy my first rodeo if you have a
dad that can watch this show you really
want in life I think oh my dad watches
shout out Dad I know your dad is good I
know I just know I never met him but I
just know it his dad is a fan I say hey
to dance Dad hi girl love your work on
Muppets or whatever
Muppets love your work on that your son
is fantastic by the way we love them
what a great guy you've grown up I mean
terrific job dad is the queen
so there it is we're not winning
why would I go if I know I'm not winning
do you want me to see because now that I
have like a team of people you want me
to see if my managers can like get more
Intel yeah okay
you think that she can until what if
we're gonna win or not yeah I'll tell
you right now we're not yeah we're not
but hey hey hey
what is this you keep talking like that
we definitely aren't winning we're not
manifesting it did I say that
um what is the
uh procedure for the voting like what
how how is it it's a black box that's
why they're so corrupt and that's why
there's no transparency and that's why I
think there's no shot absolute no
transparency the whole streamies are the
best and most notable and reliable
awards show that that YouTube has ever
seen at least nice try Olivia
she's trying you know you win more
um what the honey
you know the one thing that I will not
be able to tolerate is if they give uh
scam Paul
the award
because at least I don't think they will
and Paul
maybe call her daddy I'd say call her
daddy one last year which is why I say
possibly call her daddy and guess who
didn't show up her because she has
Integrity they call them dumps
you know wait do we know that she wasn't
there I don't think she was there to
accept that dumb how do you know
she used to call me daddy girl she got
stuff to do was she there and and so
wherever there was no she wasn't there
okay all right I'm saying Logan Paul's
probably not there he's too busy for
that there you have it
all right we'll see
is inquiring now she's a big shot
okay this was great you guys
uh the metal slide this thing's actually
been going super viral uh the Boston
slide where the camp the cop came
catapulting out
have you seen the Selah
oh my God
okay and so we were what the okay
okay
I'm not logged in by the way before
everyone tries to accuse me of having a
weird feed this is just a random thing
okay yeah
so
we're like how did that possibly happen
Okay and we said fans who live in Boston
go to the slide experiment show us and
we already got some really good results
uh here is
um some family members uh who went down
there
okay that I mean that was a far cry from
what happened to the cop though
but she was definitely
yeah she definitely hit the ground uh
running
here's one where
it looks like a torture device this one
was very thorough and I thanked them for
this I'm here to try out the infamous
metal slide just to climb a jungle gym
first
so ominous yeah nothing's so dangerous
dude you
I try not to be like a helicopter parent
but what
hers was
[Music]
I think it's a fabric Thing
100 years
that cop did not exaggerate his ass came
out like a cadaver no he did something
well I don't know what but I want to
recreate the conditions like
like and like whacked himself or they he
had to have done
can him go home go home can we get you
on one of those
I would love to do a full analysis on
that but like
he's a corpse he comes out straight up
he's also in his tummy why is that he
goes spot his ass was just getting
thrashed
there's no shot dude
what the look at this dude I
can't stop
oh I think I don't remember who said it
maybe it was cam someone had a good
theory too greasy that pig was too
greasy gross
the reverse shot is pretty good too
someone made a reverse
under B here's what it looks like in
Reverse I don't know if this reveals
anything about it but uh let's analyze
[Laughter]
there is some real funny stuff like my
Boba Pearl right before I suck it up my
straw
Peak scene right there
[Music]
all right I don't know if a person in
this uniform would be trying to make
like viral content you know
because I'm thinking like they could be
trying to exaggerate just for the video
dude he slammed his head he was dead
how could he fake that so here's what I
I'd ask more fans who are in Boston try
if you can to recreate
the conditions
go wear some slippy-ass you know clothes
a ski suit something like that
reflective vest a reflective vest
I think nylon is probably the ticket
right
slick stuff neat stuff
cool stuff
so there it is thank you to all the uh
fans out there putting in uh the
investigative reporting that we need
uh good news for everybody at home and
here in the office new scooter video
just dropped
a while unfortunately we missed the
beginning but he was clearly being a
menace this guy was on the phone with
the police he said he's being threatened
by a man in a wheelchair
I got assaulted he said he's coming back
to finish the job
again what I love about this and will
people uh you know scooter people in
general look how he's just so
he's so resigned to this fall
he doesn't move his body he doesn't try
to fight it he can't he goes down with
the watch this
like you would expect some resistance
some panicking no he knows what time it
is sound he makes it's not the first
time that's what really gets me yeah the
sound is great well he's got it oh so he
he he fell off the sidewalk and that's
what did him dirty yeah
starts walking away the other dude I
think he's turning his back to him
because he's laughing
it's like
just leave him there bro huh yeah the
cops on their way someone will find him
he's staying per it's perfect
yeah shout out to the scooter folks of
the world we love them
yeah
there it is rejoice
Kai has been arrested so that was not so
that is not a warranted uh video game
influencer was in custody after giveaway
in New York City erupted spokesman
spokesperson for the New York City
Police Department confirmed that
kaisanet
uh is in law enforcement custody oh my
God holy dude so he definitely
didn't have a permit
I mean or maybe even with the permit
they need to
because if they're responsible for
containing the crowd it's possible could
it be like just forced custody like not
necessarily like that I did something
illegal just to get him out of there
in custody
that sounds like he's being detained
but maybe you're right direct quote from
big Tom Chris they just said my name yay
Ethan Gila congrats on the pregnancy
talk this man is a is a fan for
one after one episode
that's uh big Palm
you want to call in let's get big
this is my guy we need to talk to Big
Tom
I just know this person
Chrissy if uh you're in the this word
[Music]
oh this is him being arrested oh
okay that's what I saw before
I mean dude they have helicopters out do
you know how expensive that is
in this video it kind of looks like
they're just trying to score him like uh
love saying to safety perhaps
[Music]
maybe I don't know I need to stop the
riot yeah the article actually does say
it's not immediate clear if he had been
arrested or detained additional details
weren't available he doesn't look like
he's being arrested in this that guy
actually seems to be giving him pats on
the back and stuff yeah he also posted
it on his insta story
yeah he's how long ago I don't think it
was like right a few minutes after this
tweet had come out okay
I don't think he was arrested
you know
but uh they the facts are still
developing friends this is the big oh
shred are you done yeah this is a big
moment did he finish
I think Lena is talking to the vet right
now
Shredder he gets so scared when the vet
sure
okay they take blood from him and they
do it in his chest he needs that in his
chats yeah they to put a fat needle in
his chest to get the blood out it's like
oh
poor boy well he does so good hero
Klein is my hero
they'll be just like MLK one day
um
what's next we got uh Zuck
[Music]
this talk dude I don't really I mean so
I guess Zuck has a McDonald's order I
make Meats
is Meats wait what 20 nuggets okay you
know what I don't care Zuck McDonald's
pay me if you want me to read that dumb
don't care
uh
let's see
this was a wild ride
um tell me what do you think about this
what am I watching this man just ditched
his child
up there
just gave his child to God and then
walked away
what
didn't even let he looked back once but
he's out
that's great man that kid is totally not
traumatized I love this video
Barefoot Legend yep what is he doing
I don't like watching the kid is the new
Jesus it's just Jesus too bro it's just
Jesus too just dropped it's a game of
Capture the Flag Jesus 2.0 just dropped
y'all update
and everyone just accepts it it's like
yeah
update this one's cuter
um what is this ceremony do we have any
I can get him there okay so it's so the
only information I was able to find is
that it's in Spain and um
that it's uh some ceremony about okay
hold on my my lap oh sorry go ahead my
bad
go ahead so it's uh uh for some ceremony
honoring Virgin Mary and it's barely
common
for people to want to get close to the
Effigy of Mary to I don't know get the
blessing
uh here it is this person this person
says for anyone confuses what's
happening here there's a tradition in
Spain with a more fanatical worshipers
send Babies and Children's over crowd so
that they will touch the Virgin there
you go the idea being that physical
proximity will make the Virgin protect
them in future life how about you
protect them now
you know you already failed maybe Virgin
Mary will be will do better than you
religion's so weird
um for anyone shocked do not look up
Spanish tradition of jumping over babies
I need that now we need that now that
sounds like something we probably don't
know well here don't switch to it but I
just sent some photos of it you think it
might be too up
oh well well just sort of Air Jordan
look at this Ela that's awesome bro I'm
gonna open it no no one gets hurts these
are professionals obviously don't do
this professional babies professional
faces like don't do this okay you know
what I mean like what
oh my God
that's a high stakes game of Mario now
can you do me a favor has a has a baby
ever been injured we don't even know how
to be babies better than all the others
because there's got to be one time at
least where everyone was laughing and
this dude just face planted on a baby or
I mean foot planted
all right listen I don't want to think
about it but local said there are no
records of babies really ever been
harmed during the jumping portion of the
festival yeah they're not reporting that
although the jumping portion what
about the other portions well I think
that something on the baby's portion is
the one that people are concerned I mean
that's that's pretty good air oh and the
parents are there so if he's about to
land they might be able to what the body
well you could I don't know
that's pretty good air
why they got dudes in capes
[Music]
in Spain dude yeah chill bro they're the
counts
it's the count
one two three five
the count song
one two three dance beautiful yeah the
sick ass Sesame Street song
the videos are wild I gotta see
that I don't want pictures I want I want
to see that
but this guy's a lunatic I mean this is
next level on top of everything
that poor child uh that kid looks like
maybe two yeah that's pretty durable
Loki like he just stays you could have
fallen easy I agree I think watch it
look it's kind of shaking around watch
that first like I think maybe that is a
type of Jesus I think that should
worship yeah
yeah he's pretty durable he's pretty
steady yeah
that's what they say I think about Jesus
was steady all right babies oh I love
their outfits
Little Legends out here
so cool cool all right well they got a
nice little mattress uh oh here come the
jumpers
that guy's looking middle-aged I need a
younger jumper yeah for sure you know I
mean that guy's
I want my baby jumper spry so is this
what tradition looks like because I
don't know anything about traditions
this is the fortnite lobby dude yeah you
know
in Europe they they brag about their
history and their traditions and their
how they have I mean this is what you're
talking about looks fun
nice angle yeah baby point of views
I want to have a GoPro on the baby yeah
the neighbors
this dude's in like one of the mark he
caught like a feather or something and
turned into a baby jumper
that was a little odd heat jumped dude
he almost skim their face bro
you better be hopping more than that
brother again some of these babies can
sit up like what if they just happen to
get up at that moment bro you better
jump like your life depends I don't like
bro that guy's sitting out he's shaving
it too close in my opinion this is very
interesting I've never heard of this
Kobe
that would be fire if there was a rim
behind them
what now babies the you up
to americanize this transition but you
know what I'm saying though you know
what Americans don't have tradition they
say
I'll jump a baby I mean what the
that's it you guys been around for
thousands of years and this is you got
the jumping the baby that's what you
guys came up with oh thanks to this guy
apparently it's his footage appreciate
it shout out Fearless fearless and far
it was so far you know
the babies look like they're having fun
though yeah
until they get stomped on purpose which
never happened it's never happened after
that let the cows lose and they like
just jump over
the rules yes the ball comes right after
him now that's tradition yeah that's
tradition don't they do that in Spain
too you're telling me you're telling me
in the thousands of years they've been
doing that ain't no baby got curb
stomped oh that's horrible to say
all right uh
uh thousands of years ago it happened
because God did that's right they're
protecting
um 1620 is when the tradition
started as a melding of pagan and
Catholic Traditions like most most of
Christianity although its exact Origins
are unclear that is not officially
sanctioned by the Catholic Church
I could jump those babies I want to see
the pope jump the babies Oh you gotta
pay big money for that
all right and we'd probably get an
upskirt from the pope if he jumped in
with the baby POV
bro you know he's got some saggers too
man mad droopers like Hang Low
Sweet chariots hey dude a
day
stop
you'd see those J his droopers probably
falling right out the bottom of those
man they might rub the babies on the
face which is not appropriate
maybe the pope jumping isn't a good idea
no okay
show us no no no no no well no no no no
no no
everybody go ahead Zach go ahead
no no no no no no no that's why I hit
show us you get a little taste I'm not
hitting the full thing
that's file man what's wrong with you
Zach
you're unnoticed man
um
here is we're doing this because it's
just sitting there I know I know well
okay right let me work through this and
then we'll go to that we'll do we can do
the xqc thing afterwards because nobody
seems to give a about that guy
anyway
I feel like anyone who's not one of his
die-hard fans literally is like I cannot
stand this guy
have you noticed that
are you still a fan of his and no
judgment I mean I I would enjoy his
content I don't watch him really you can
enjoy his contacts I can enjoy his
content yeah
all right
okay well one's one person dies one
person lives him
he dies he dies thanks bro you pass you
passed the test yeah
did they put that question in your
interview with the embassy they did yeah
yes do you plan to commit a terrorist
act they ask questions oh yeah a bunches
like nope do you plan to carry out a
biochemical attack on millions of people
no any plans on a PS5 giveaway
wait love I do have this recording
um
whoa I don't remember them asking that
question so I think I'm good got it I
don't know the NBC might need to hear
that oh no cam dug up uh a later part of
that same ceremony yeah this is what I
was scared of they've done the same guy
oh my God
okay you're telling me a baby's never
been hurt oh Cam come on no the Virgin
Mary protects them dude the Virgin Mary
protection okay don't believe the media
there's just babies everywhere that is
so up
get it together Spain
time to join the modern day
hasta la vista baby oh literally
all right so anyway
um
this is a cool story that involves post
Malone it's just like a weird thing
so magic the Gathering made a Lord of
the Rings collab card that was one of
one
oh the one ring okay and so
this dude pulled it
s hands are shaking people were already
trying to buy it before anyone even
pulled it it's like the golden ticket
wow people were like oh I'm putting out
an offer there's only one card one of
one wow and people were like I'll give
you half a million dollars straight up
right out to whoever gets a standing
offer
but the person that actually ended up
buying the car
is friend of the show and you know last
time we were with him he's like heavily
into Magic the Gathering yeah he bought
the card from him for two
million dollars oh my God over 2 million
oh my God
how cool is that
that's crazy you better what's
he gonna do with the card do you frame
it do you play with it no you don't play
with it you frame it you definitely put
it in her
hermetic seal
something that thing will age
that we'll appreciate for sure you go
back to Mordor to destroy it throw it in
a lava yeah exactly that's crazy I doubt
he'll ever sell that too yeah it's
probably like gone from the market
forever can you believe paying that much
for a card I think it's badass that he
can afford it and he just did the story
around it is so cool too
you know but he is really like he really
loves Magic the Gathering so
we have some
[Music]
I mean I I am not nearly as into it as I
used to be but when I was a teenager I
played quite a bit I had a fairly large
collection and I'll still play every
once in a while
uh just uh recently uh Ian got super
into it right like within the last year
or two I was playing it a bit Sam has
been playing the the mobile thing a lot
too oh I play online I really I love it
it's so much fun what's your favorite
card
know I don't know that much about it I
don't know anything about it I just
thought that might be a good learning
I'm doing like the um
there's like a whole beginning part of
like tutorial stuff so I'm still playing
with like the training wheels on but
it's still really fun
I love it yeah it seems fun well there
might be something cool happening
because they say something or no
[Music]
would you put it on clothing
I could I don't know I could see that
[Music]
I bet that'd be a good idea that'd be a
cool collection because they have so
much cool art
it'd be cool
would be so cool
here we are moving on the quartering is
crying about what now
he's always crying about something if
it's not his wife leaving for pizza
without him it's you know Barbie being
too pink
I must defend Ethan Klein it is one of
the most difficult things I have to do
sorry to make you do that brother look
I'm 40. I'm tired I'm sweaty I'm fat I'm
overweight
so the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle movie
yes the one where with the turtles they
got transformed into humanoid ninjas
yeah
uh so they made Splinter gay in the new
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle because is
Splinter gay and is that even true no
look look at the right up below like why
would
uh according to director Jeff Rowe
scumbag is and always was a female
cockroach however in one poster
marketing mistakenly referred to it as a
himself wow I had no idea wait what does
it have to do with splinter
Splinter is not gay guys
we have to be a gay or being black is
different and we have to set the record
straight here guys
splinter
is not gay
thank God
what does this cockroach have to do with
Splinter being gay the cockroach is uh
the love interest oh Splinter that
thing well I don't know I haven't seen
it yet so I don't I don't know but uh
that that's where this all came from was
just okay so so splint so scumbag the
cockroach is a Girl by Canon yeah this
poster they actually wrote himself and
then quartering had a full-on meltdown
about it because of normal behavior yeah
just this this winter this I
bought a drawing of a bug it says
himself and then so he he had a meltdown
about it yeah Splinter uh Splinter is a
rat a rat and a cockroach is still
pretty crazy but better hold on if a
male rat has sex with a male cockroach
are we worried about the gender that
seems to transcend gender at that point
right that's just inner species
relations yeah that's a whole different
ball game why aren't you offended by
that you're telling me a cockroach
a rat that's completely different
tell me more oh I just I just hope Danny
Danny's in them
he probably is okay with bestiality as
long as it's not male with Mel that's
right no gay bestiality only
heterobiciality for important
what a dumbass this is literally the
state of conservative media right now
well I'm overweight
does he it I almost feel like he has to
be trolling but I I he's not I always
tell myself that and he really is
dude he's just that dumb so no he's the
real deal he's so funny
he is the real deal boy
um
okay that's funny picture I have to give
it up that's my Michael uh what's his
name Michael Rapport who's always doing
these uh epic rants yeah but there's
this picture of him with a fat herpes
sore
I guess everybody just posted
nasty filthy sloppy disgusting I mean
animals listen it happens to
people it's not it's you know it means
it's unfortunate when it does but
it's out there I find the quartering so
unbelievably humorous it's crazy I know
he rolls
uh totally totally Olivia's got soft
spot yeah blueberry cobbler coffee
there's something sweet happening yeah
there's something with it that's so good
out of jail why do you care how could a
guy that spends his whole free time
playing claw machines and sending kids
and toys to kids be a bad guy why do you
care yeah why do you care okay Chris uh
uh uh
what's his name Tristan Tristan Tate
made a new tick tock alpha male edit
about me now do we know for sure he's
talking about me so this is from a fan
Channel and it was uploaded yesterday
and yeah it was called uh Tristan calls
out H3 does it have a lot of views uh
let me double check 10 million views see
it's a fan Channel I almost wonder if
it's just deceptively edited I'm just
right these hey brothers have a
bajillion little drones that just post
these videos all day on Tick Tock so who
knows
um
but I got some traction right I do want
to know how many views I got I'm always
interested to know
at least it doesn't there's not me
saying that I hate exercising it so I
guess that's progress I believe they
actually just today uh I saw uh their
hassle arrest got lifted so they're out
on the loose
the Tates oh they got released yeah I
read it but they can't leave the city
right yeah they're just they're not
confined they're still they're so
yeah yeah they're definitely
going to jail 5K views oh oh I guess my
name just doesn't doesn't do what it
used to for the ape owner is it's faded
shame it's because you lost weight
right that might be it that's right
well here's Tristan Tate apparently go
out of jail and send me some clips of
some dorm laughing at the back we were
in jail and I was like I'm not in jail
he's in jail Andrew taint this man's in
jail rotting so awesome
he's sitting there online every day
glued to his podcast to make super tests
to pay his bills he's more in jail than
I will ever be I'm standing in myself
muscular fit strong my mind is free my
mind is open oh yeah well you're on
house arrest I can go outside and do it
this man literally said I'm free because
I have muscles yay
in jail
yeah yeah dude no I'm really struck I'm
really try I'm imprisoned man yeah I
just I just want to say you're
addressing Andrew not Tristan yeah
nobody cares yeah you never like I don't
think I've ever said Tristan until this
time yeah I didn't even know how to say
his name right uh taint but you know
it's
he wants to be involved so bad that's a
good point that's a true State yes
nobody ever even talks about you taint
this doesn't feel bad for him you're
just the brother of
yeah if your brother wants to make a
compilation I'll watch it but who are
you even it's not your fault I will ever
do we see if this get claimed by the way
oh there's no clue okay I'm standing in
my cell muscular fit is strong my mind
is free my mind is open oh yeah well
you're on house arrest I can go outside
and do whatever I want whatever you want
take a walk around the neighborhood oh
and I'm locked in my nine bedroom
mansion with my pool with my friend
again not talking about you what he goes
he goes yo you can go take a walk well
I'm locked in my Mansion yeah what kind
of a loser with all my Bros by the way
okay here friends are my chefs and my
Butlers with hundreds of thousands of
people listening to me when I speak oh
you can go outside and do whatever you
want you can do whatever you want when
I'm free I can go to private jet and go
to Timbuktu if I won I can do whatever
you want to do that no that's just
actually completely false yeah you can't
leave again I mean at the time of this
recording you're gonna leave he can't
even leave his house right right
all right so I don't know I guess yeah I
mean I guess you know there is a there
is a kind of a metaphysical
sense of freedom I mean when you think
about like the Shawshank Redemption when
he was in solitary confinement he was
playing music in his head they couldn't
get to his mind and so maybe that's what
he means you know sure
so even though he cannot leave his house
his mind is free his mind is free and
Powers is not my mind is not free
because I'm fat by the way apparently oh
so it is a kind of a fat thing too to
his podcast to make super tests to pay
his bills he's more in jail than ever do
you even sex traffic
that's what freedom is
it will ever be I'm standing in my cell
muscular fit strong my mind is free my
mind is open oh yeah bro you literally
just spent 75 describing free as being
strong anyway whatever a trait to
whatever your Tristan
nobody cares man
put your brother on the phone
nobody wants to talk to you it is what
it is
um okay Joe Rogan has completely lost
his mind let's go no no this is
this is the I think he's he's fully gone
over the edge I want to see you this is
Rock Bottom I mean I don't do you agree
Dan
you saw this clip right yeah
to be honest this doesn't seem any worse
than what he's been for the last like
two years I don't know I I've never
heard him say this so explicitly
before we watch actually I have a
question are you guys getting hungry
because I hear Dan cheering on chips
Dan's munching chips I'm here eating
sour candy what are you feeling I'm kind
of hungry
Samsung great I know that
I feel this he's disappearing my God
um
oh yeah we just lost power
is the stream still up
whoa
chat is still happening
we lost
half of the power uh it's looking to me
like we're still alive wow that's
perfect
so I guess we got lucky on that one
huh
pledge so we're good we're up
uh it's looking like I'm working to
confirm yeah it looks like all the
backups worked
Legend a hot day out here in Los Angeles
did it come back on it's a rainy day out
here in Los Angeles okay yeah definitely
it didn't even blip it's the main okay
yeah we're up nice
I did it folks good so that was your
backup and power all the backups were
yeah yeah
save the day just redid it too that's
yeah we did it when we moved everything
around
are you guys tired of Taco Bell yet or
are we still in listen whatever you want
you're preg you're the pregnant one I'll
follow your lead you won't take TB
really
holy she turns into a completely
different person when she's pregnant
like yeah it's crazy yeah it's crazy you
want Taco Bell let's go right now dad
I guess just message who wants to take
the point on that oh so just message to
Sam I guess in the group chat
all right what is white lizzo sorry I
have to click this what
yeah keep in mind you're on Twitter oh
is it Chris Christie I believe it is
Chris Christie
I mean I can I only okay I don't see a
lot of similarities between them except
one
yeah
all right here's Joey
uh with the craziest take I've heard
yeah and the people that that love Trump
they feel like this is a Witch Hunt and
they feel like all the things he's
getting indicted for are anyway
not only does it not work but it kind of
hardens their position that he's being
targeted and that this is these are like
the the actions of a Banana Republic you
take your political rival and you arrest
him and specifically you charge him with
things that you're guilty of I I
don't disagree the Optics of it is
pretty crazy like from the outside but
like Trump is a psychopath
a minute huh I agree
I mean Optics of arresting your
political opponent
in it's not a good situation Society
like politicians get arrested yeah what
I mean like to me it's more Banana
Republic that you can try and
overthrow the government and and get
away with it and nobody does anything
and what does Banana Republic even mean
by the way well it's in a reference to
all of the Central American countries
and that's here's another layer of irony
is the banana republics are you know
like Honduras and Guatemala and all
these countries that were largely uh
their entire economy was like fruit and
as and the American fruit companies came
in and were basically running the
country by just like bribing all the
officials and it was like super corrupt
so the banana republics we we made those
you know what I mean like the the thing
that was corrupt about them the
corrupting influence was U.S business
interests and so
um that's a small Min or it's like a
manipulable corrupt government
right at the United States specifically
has created right so there's a little
bit of irony in in calling
you know that's like a parent being like
people corruption is actually being
prosecuted that makes us a Banana
Republic It's to me it's like it's the
exact opposite of that so I can
see why from their perspective it looks
like that right even though what you're
saying is objectively the truth right
uh it's not a good situation but it is
what it is I get what he you're right
that he has somewhat of a point with
like yeah I mean he's correct that it's
definitely hardening the opinions of all
the people that think he did he did
nothing wrong and they indicted him yeah
he did everything right he's speaking to
his audience and like they're all like
dude
he's indicted three times like to them
it's just becoming a joke
but Joe Rogan is a I mean
his brain is made of ground beef at this
point and egg yolk I did everything
right and they indicted me I don't think
there's anything left in that nut in
that he's just like a human like like
Walnut
then crack them open and just release
the nut I don't know what that means
sometimes I just talk figure it out as
we go yeah some sometimes it just goes
off the rails
um oh Tate gave a press
we have breaking news yeah okay jail
cell
seven or eight months later on the news
sorry well here we are seven and eight
minutes later and or years later or
months later what
or eight months later and I'd love to
see the same victim on the news
the did he say I don't know
clicking from the cameras is too loud I
see lots of girls sticking up for me
lots of people defending me outside
it's very exhausted ah boring
nobody care who gives a you
I've heard it you suck times yeah you're
going you're waiting to hear from your
lawyer Andrew
are not supposed to be being sued by him
yeah like a year ago no updates it's so
funny because this was before he got
arrested they said
you're calling my client a sex
trafficker and that's defamation and we
demand that you retract and erase all
the content
and then six months later remember it
was like a month later you got arrested
uh so what I mean he was arrested for
human trafficking now can I defame
somebody
who was arrested for the for the crime
that I allege they did I don't think so
right on
that's like if I said Bill Cosby's a
rapist
and his lawyer said don't say that about
our boy
you know Prime
all right back to Joe
I love Trump they feel like this is a
Witch Hunt and they feel like all the
things he's getting indicted for are
anyway not only does it not
work but it kind of hardens their
position that he's being targeted and
that this is these are like the the
actions of a Banana Republic you take
your political rival and you arrest him
and specifically you charge him with
things that you're guilty of
like the the the documents like it's sad
that Joe Rogan is such a and and
like if he's saying something like this
this open because he's one of these guys
that becomes a prisoner to his audience
he's he's spit speaking what they all
feel
obviously yeah I mean we've it doesn't
take that long to figure out what's the
difference between the two the
difference is
uh the Library of Congress asked Joe
Biden for the documents and he
immediately returned them
okay
they asked Trump three times they
subpoenaed him
he never released it he was obstructing
and not returning it I mean what the
there's a difference dude
a man
the classified documents Biden's guilty
of the exact same issue you you gotta
respect oh and then it's this
guy
oh yeah yeah
it's another conservative uh podcaster
a level of deception oh he invited me on
the show didn't he
yeah he's invited on his show many times
actually oh yes you made me defend this
dude I'm not doing that you
actually the reason I don't go on uh to
be fair is they talk they get really
in the weeds with politics and that's
just not my thing
but uh wish you the best there budo
that's been used I mean look at what
Hillary did going and saying hey it's
Russia but it was really you know what
she was doing another one can you repeat
that
look what Hillary did she was saying
it's Russia but it's what she really did
okay
and in order to comprehend you're gonna
have to break something I got you
comprehension the
omelets of knowledge you're gonna have
to break those eggshells yeah and
incidentally preach was actually more
coherent than yeah this guy right now I
mean look at what yeah Sam Cedar went on
his podcast and he destroyed him of
course Hillary did going and saying hey
it's Russia but it was really you know
what she was doing right they're using a
similar play as well right how much
election fraud do you think is real here
we go Joe oh somebody said go on Jesse
Peter I want to talk about a Langston
fraud dude wait somebody said go on
Jesse Peterson I would I think I would
go on his show I love him yes he's the
oh you're gay
I would love to go on a show it's so off
the walls crazy I'm rude I'm genuinely a
fan of his in like a weird morbid
up way but that's that's why everybody
he's the best yeah
less begins
if you want to go to election fraud yeah
because I don't think it's zero no it's
not zero I think we could all agree
based on what I cannot agree
well we've got time how long is this
podcast three four hours go ahead
explain that no way it's not zero and we
know that these voting machines can be
with yeah
I mean yeah no Dominion literally won
800 million dollars from Fox News yeah
just like six months ago for saying this
there's I don't think there is any
evidence that uh voting machines
in a national election have been
tampered with right I mean I don't think
that's ever happened
know that there's some irregularities uh
all that that carry Lake stuff and
Carrie Lane they're trying to dismiss it
doesn't look like that's invalid Harry
lake is like the nuttiest Mega
weirdo that was did so many recounts and
just kept losing and losing and losing
and he's out here talking about how her
election was stolen
holy dude looks like there's real
fraud there it looks like there's some
real Shenanigans there at the very least
there was voting machines that weren't
working properly really and it seems
very suspicious that a lot of them were
in Republican areas
there's a lot of shenanigans oh my God
and I think there's coordinated efforts
to make sure that certain people get
elected yeah it's called the it's called
the DNC and the RNC dummy
wow I don't know to me that was yeah
this is kind of shocking to come out
with the election fraud that brazenly
yeah
just me I guess
and you
all right let's do the candy tier list
is there any setting up for it because I
kind of need to go potty we found the
bathroom okay
a bunch of super chats I could read go
ahead
okay
dude okay you take care of that
all right let's see what we got here uh
we got Dan Nancy's uh 22nd birthday I
don't know how to use Discord well sorry
we can't play anything for you
geez
about that Nance
hey Nancy
happy birthday
22.
all right oh I had the wrong name I'm
sorry it's a flesh burger that turned 20
uh no Nancy also okay sorry there's a
lot of birthdays here I got you Nancy
bless Burger is 22. Nancy's 27.
going to have him so we're gonna get a
hold you get a little uh 27 there thank
you 27. uh this person is turning 20.
I can we can we have it can we just
have an open discussion about this and I
don't want people to feel bad but like
the birthday like shout out now are you
also over it or are you with Zach or
against Zach right now
I I'm I personally am over it
and Zach but I understand why people get
excited and I don't I don't want to to
crush their dreams or make them feel bad
but it's just like I have so many people
dming their driver's money like
I'm in super chats right now
it's all like can I get a birthday shout
out can I get a birthday shout out okay
so frankly no let no you can let
me break this down
it was funny
the the the history of the birthday
shout out has a good fun illustrious
history that Aiden Ross I'm 21 you
you know and then we started making
people give their IDs and then Aiden
Ross we got Aiden Ross AI to say the all
the numbers right so we have we have we
exhausted the jokes jump the shark over
let's jump into the shark a little bit
jump to shark are you sure because I
wonder if there's another chat don't get
me wrong like I I do wish you a happy
birthday but
dude I got a 65 year old in uh DM
yesterday sent me a picture of her
driver's license
not just the disclaimer be careful when
you're sending that out but yo
let's go to Chase and open an account
six seven eight and I feel bad because
these people they donated and oftentimes
it's a lot like 20 donation here 10
donations they gotta send more I don't
want to on you for this but it's
just getting to be too okay so let's
just say this so people don't waste
money and be disappointed that we don't
do the birthday wish
so here we're going to do one big giant
birthday wish for everybody wow a big
old happy birthday to every single one
of you guys you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna try something here I'm
just I'm gonna go through the numbers
starting at 20. so this is the this is
the final
Ride This Is The Final Countdown this is
the last one and everybody savor it and
save it save the sound bite and play it
for yourself when you're yeah you know
you're gonna cry Olivia
[Music]
yes I think it's more exciting to keep
the potentiality open send us your money
and we might do it
I understand your point but I do I don't
I feel bad that people actually do that
so go ahead Zach we're gonna do like our
final salute I'm I'm gonna start at 21.
and that's going to be it can you get
can you do me a favor yes you know how
like um military funerals they shoot
guns in the air
um so do the number and then the fire
the rifle
um number fire the rifle we're retiring
we're bearing Dan do you want to help me
with the gun sounds okay sure can you do
it we'll do a little back and forth here
and then if you can play some patriotic
kind of funeralish like drumming
like no no like uh it's probably on a
saxophone or you know like there's kind
of a hymn uh like maybe taps
you know like a glory
caps the the memories
funeral music you'll find something good
okay so I'm going to start at 21. hold
on we got the music gunshots hold on
we're not ready Zach while we're waiting
on that Olivia your birthday present
just came what do you mean
oh my God thank you so much thank you
avian Lena got me literally the coolest
Barbie Crocs you've ever seen in your
life they were the most me shoes I've
ever seen can't wait for everyone else
to see them in that bag no they gave
those to me over the weekend oh that's
so nice that's cute Barbie Crocs Dan is
it okay if Olivia has a quick birthday
moment
of course it's loud okay okay thanks
thank you you have to pay though why are
you asking dad that's okay I got that
because Dan was canceling birthdays I'm
not canceling all birthdays okay
this is awesome
this is the
um
the dad from Twilight
are you sure that's not for a b
it's a very seems like an AB shirt we
both love Twilight that's fire I love
that spread
thank you guys so much I love this I
can't wait to wear it no problem
okay so um do we have the music you
think the death bell would work good
like do you think that I could pull here
let me pull something up yeah yeah yeah
that's it that's it no that was me I'm
looking for a good 21 gun salute sound
effect
Green Day I'm looking for the gun line
guys bear with us this is important to
do right obviously as we memorialize the
birthday wishes we want to
you know eulogize them properly and send
them on their way of course and the most
respectful way possible of course of
course of course
with peace and love no more birth this
is a serious message to everybody
donating right now with peace and love I
want to tell you please
after August 4th no more birthday wishes
and no
numbers to be said I think we need some
like bagpipes
yes I think we should
you're not finding anything good there
Dan oh I found I found the gunshots I'm
ready with the gunshots all right let me
find music funeral I'll find one with
her we're gonna collaborate on this
just hopefully this doesn't get claimed
that I don't know but it's worth it
is it probably not
there it is
[Music]
you
25 26.7
[Music]
20 30.
31.
32.
33. 34.
[Music]
36.
37. 38.
[Music]
39. how many do we have
we're bearing them all how old do people
get we're bearing them all
last one
42. that was not eating rice whoever
said that number
wow
[Music]
oh
it's been a good meme but sometimes you
have to bury the jokes sometimes the
jokes overstay their welcome
that we must bury them in the graveyard
with all the heroes the Fallen you know
Patriots
from before them
and so with that being said with peace
and love no more birthday wishes please
after August 4th no sounds to be said
nothing
so peace and love peace and love Noah
birthday wishes thank you thank you
and happy birthday and happy yeah one
happy birthday that's the last birthday
ever happy birthday happy birthday happy
birthday
all right thank you
that was good
I feel I feel light now I feel like I
feel like we're refreshed yeah we needed
to grieve like that we needed a grief
all right let's do some sour candy yes
all right so here's the goal of this
okay as I as I stated in the beginning
this all started from FaZe rugs
candy sour candy challenge this was
marketed as the most sour thing in the
world the challenge was to put it in
your mouth and hold it there for like 30
seconds without making a face
so we all went in like this is going to
be crazy it wasn't it wasn't at all in
fact and we're like these probably
Warheads are are more spite are more
sour by the way this was twenty dollars
that's part of what was such a scam
about this
um so
there's not even a QR code to win like
Tesla 10 bucks or something yeah Tesla
yeah so here's what we're gonna do
we are raiding these candies
not on taste or enjoyment okay solely
only on sourness okay we are trying to
figure out
who is the king of the sour candies and
also I'm really curious to see where
this shakes out yeah this supposed sour
challenge right a 20 Warhead essentially
okay and so with all that being said
oh and then finally the finale of course
is Sam's homemade yeah sour can that's
right which we might need to package
that thing up with a
with a QR code you know what I'm saying
there's there's an ad in this look at
this download cash app and get
foreign bucks oh no it doesn't say that
I did
still hasn't had all right so where do
we begin so let's open the list
I got it up here
I mean I think what we can do is start
with the you want to start with the FaZe
rug one no that's I don't I think we
have to put it in the middle somewhere
or laugh frankly to get a real yeah okay
well you can see all of the candies
along the bottom here I can't see the uh
tier list are we supposed to use this
one because oh did that oh when the
power went out that tv reset sorry yeah
one second so I think we should start
with the more obviously not going to be
spicy ones like sour skittles it's sour
I've been eating that me too it's good
it's no problem and every you all have
what we're doing right so guys thank you
again
everybody we're gonna do the sour
Skittle put your balls in my mouth what
ah dude I love sour skittles
love them tastes good yeah I've been
loving it it's a good sour no not too
sour
in the uh pre-show uh live stream chat I
was seeing some disdain for sour
skittles I feel like it's a
controversial candy Chad tell me if I'm
wrong about that
um I was seeing a lot of call outs on
the sour skittles I don't like Skittles
at all I don't love them all right
really
the sour skittles is probably gonna be a
f or a d on the sour list on the
sourness like I guess F would be like
nothing F's nothing there's just like a
d I will say I'm gonna take one of these
bags home
yeah we have like a whole Costco
like baseball the mini league
size
you do I don't know what I'm saying my
brain don't work so good you know what I
realize about it yeah you have like a
whole bag you know it just reminds me
when you're playing little league you
get a whole bunch of little candies and
there's always someone selling it
slinging those does does sour candy give
any of you guys like the rumbles at all
the tummy rumbles yeah does it make you
at all no as I get older I'm
realizing sour candy what it
hurts my stomach yeah
is there anything that doesn't make you
another question no could it be food
itself that makes you right but you
know there's like certain things that
make you rush to the bathroom
okay it doesn't have that effect on me
I'm really curious about this
we can do that one next I don't know
what the this is but it looks two
of them here so mix it this is Mega this
is liquid candy
yeah
slime liquor sour rolling liquid candy
never heard of it
my tongue
so what do you do should we do this one
yeah we can do them if you like okay so
have you opened the top yet and seen
what's going on here that's so fun it's
like a deodorant dude that is so wild
isn't that crazy and you just lick the
ball I'm obsessed with this
okay these candies are so vile do you
lick it and then you put it back and you
lick it again there's no way that's not
like a material
oh I guess you mean like people close it
and return literally growing like
deadly bacteria on this it is it is very
good mine is not sour at all me neither
there's no sour to this it's like nuts
really
wow
yeah that's like sweet it's just sweet
it's so weird this is also so funny
thing ever maybe shake it there's no
flavor I wonder should you oh you have
to roll the floor yeah You're Gonna Roll
the bowl oh yeah you have to like roll
them I'm not trying to eat a fountain
pen
ballpoint pen it's like a tiny bit sour
it just tastes like a like a
what the are you supposed to even
do with this it just tastes like one of
those Ecto Cooler drinks I want to take
out the box I think that's enough liquid
if you squeeze it really hard it comes
out yeah oh maybe you gotta squeeze
because like I barely have any coming
out you have to really work the balls
yeah you have to really work the ball
okay
it's a little sour yeah it's just a tiny
bit sour I think it's a D in my opinion
I think it's an F I mean it's horrible
it is the worst candy ever why please
don't anyone buy this it's gonna make me
give it a c
so okay I mean I guess it is less sour
than the
okay let's see we did these then the
Skittles so let's go f then
and the ball part isn't even candy they
should have made that part candy at
least bro yeah is this just plastic yes
which is possible I've been ignoring on
it you've been trying to get through it
me too yeah I think it's just a ball of
plastic I thought it was like lollipop
gnawing on it
let's see it
yo you're like one of the girls from um
lizzo's strip club that's right yeah
wow
talk about a buzz ball
that's disgusting
well there it is uh well done love the
bad how would you rate the sourness
that's the only one who went in less
than Skittle so it's an F yeah it's an F
okay they really hyped it up with that
name toxic waste yeah yeah they're like
no it's just really vile it's yeah
nothing to do with the taste it's just
really disgusting toxic waste train how
about sour punch mini bites next goaded
do it which one
these look good sour punch mini bites so
those are the little tubies right I
think so yeah these are nice I never had
that
dude
this is hmm I think it's also a deep uh
that's it it's a little sour
I feel like the Skittles that we already
put ID was more sour than this stuff
I wonder if that one needs to move up
I don't think we can move Skittles up no
it's just not that sour you know
honestly this one's making me pucker up
a little bit really what this one has a
little I feel like it's not sour at all
really it's pretty much the same huh I'm
willing to give it I'd say it's about
the same as the sour skittles maybe
slightly more I would say oh yeah
pucker in your anus no it's my not my
anus yet okay I'll let you know
[Laughter]
okay so it seems like a d
okay nice though
I hate this candy really what about it
uh F tier easy oh come on why do you
want to put an F here you know
[Music]
go ahead
he called on you
where did where did Ian go he was just
talking about candies
Ian what's wrong Ian
I did not like it okay he didn't like it
so guys let's move on to Lily's sour
gummy worms okay so what I never heard
this brand I don't know what I'm looking
for here with the lilies
Sweet Life these are the uh worms that
are more like transparent the trolley
ones are okay they're like the natural
one yeah the skin whoa dude wait I gotta
say something about these these worms I
guess they're like healthy worms so this
whole listen to this this whole patch
has 70 grams of calories not a lot but
here's where it gets really interesting
dietary fiber 24 grams 85 of your daily
oh wow what order what are these go
right to the bathroom don't give them
too much credit until you eat it well
it's like a healthy they're like organic
that's some healthy candy yeah
I think it's like those Metamucil
garments have been hitting
I'm gonna go d
D Ian I'm gonna disagree I think it's a
f
uck
yeah
I agree yeah Lily's
yeah f for me vitamin gummies are
tastier yeah great let's get some
Flintstones up in here dude hell yeah
dude gummy worms turned woke into the
garbage Flintstone it's an app I think
we think F because yeah it was a little
sour whereas this one again the toxic
slime was like nothing I thought it was
less sour than the two above so we're
going just based on sourness that's what
we're going off of yeah
I
I had to go Steve on it
yeah I like it I like the consistency no
no sourness
oh you just said yeah but we can't throw
any other factors into it you literally
asked just sourness and we said yes I
don't live by the rules here I don't
live by the rule he's a Maverick okay
then in that case f but Zach if you like
it you should munch on those because it
that's a lot of fiber bro I already got
I don't there's no problem there today
dude
okay can we do these sour belts
strawberry those look awesome I'm
excited about these I like tub candy it
says sweet with a z
sweet yeah usually if candy comes in a
tub you're gonna have a good time with
it
look at this you can get real wild with
these
are you showing this Ian so cute
they came with a little tweezer here you
are
what are you freaking out about Zach
look at this this one it's like really
sweet why does it look like bacon wait
why is that
you're disgusted by these Zach I think
these are delicious yeah I really like
what is happening back there are you
gonna say anything that was disgusting
yeah I like sour Bells what the is
that no it's good oh that was good it's
literally like a normal ass candy You're
With Me Sam yeah I don't like it ha
I mean you're on not obligated to like
it okay well
on sourness though again we're not
getting any plates it's got a week and
I'm starting to wonder if maybe we need
to expand our tears because the first
Skittles so far was the most sour for me
yeah I almost feel like no snuggles and
sour punch C and this is D and these
remain F really that's I feel like that
we need to yeah problem things up a
little bit it's our scale serve this
great well these ones were a D in my
opinion do you want to move Skittles up
to see I think Skittles and maybe these
to see
let me try this again and and the belts
now are the new D Baseline
that's my proposal
would anyone like to second that
proposal seconded okay we have a second
thank you I definitely agree with that
oh we have a third okay I'm a man of the
people I just hit another sour Skittle
and they're definitely the most sour
thing so yeah so far sour skittles are
definitely the most they don't strike me
as very sour yeah I agree but but more
than anything else yeah yeah more than
that okay so and what how do we feel
about the sour punch no that's a d these
remain D that one was yeah okay okay
and then we what are these called zweets
uh belts those are D sour strips does
this one no that's the blue ones
sour strips
let's do that so that's the blue strip
right yeah okay this one so you know
Zach
has no fiber
okay are you guys drinking water in
between
um he's got a little more sourdough hmm
I think we're getting somewhere
loving these ones that's good
oh real good chemical that's sour oh
that's that's sour yeah
[Music]
so that's probably a b you think really
or a
no no no it's not a I don't think it's a
but it might be I think it's higher than
the Skittles so maybe the thing is once
you hit this extra sour Warhead you will
understand
I know but like even a I think is too
honorable
of a spot so B sounds like I think these
are Skittle flavor or the same same
mosquitoes I found it a little bit more
than Skittles but yeah I'm open to push
back there
throw me another strip bro I need
another sour strip you can have the
whole thing just pulling that over
oh so um
I I put those C honestly I mean it's you
know it's just not it's nothing that
crazy what does everybody else think b
or c
C for me oh I agree yeah okay really I'd
say beep again once again the man of the
people I have to go with with uh my
subjects on this
be it is B yeah okay
okay
all right we're working our way up
now the Sour Patch Kids I love these
this is my favorite fantastic sour candy
I mean these things
never disappoint boy
in fact when last time we were in New
York remember there was a Sour Patch
Kids store yeah there's a store you get
a tin and the shape of a Sour Patch Kid
and you just feel it's like they
challenge you to fill it up with as much
as you can
so we had a tinted this in our house for
months I just went through that sour
though hmm
what does something like that cost I
don't even remember and they said a
YouTuber owns sour strips
really really Max tuning I'm looking it
up right now respect wow that's great
those were the most flavorful those were
good they Rock they're great yeah
entrepreneur eat more sour strips yeah
okay shout out Max tuning got a good
product there
um
these are not that sour probably I would
put it probably C
[Music]
um I feel like it was more sour than
sour strips no what flavor did you have
more sour I had the red one I felt like
At first it was sweet then there was
wait but this you're talking about the
red sour strips right no I'm I was
talking about Sour Patch Kids we're
doing now right no I get it but what
were you saying I had a red Sour Patch I
think that that was to me more sour than
the blue strips
what color Sour Patch did you I think
they're all the same sour they're all
just coated interesting they're rolled
in some kind of sour concoction what is
everyone's sour try that my bag was not
sour maybe try this really what do you
guys do for your sour sampling method do
you put it on your tongue and you suck
it or like do you just do cheese no I
roll it around yeah
it's sweet
I feel like that's not sour at all yours
aren't dusted at all about that dust
yeah wow we gotta get some quality
control from the gummy bear people
the Patch Kids
yeah I think they're
I think they're D frankly
on sour level just didn't do it for me
either yeah like it there's some
sourness there but it's it's not
intensive okay well we're working our
way up to this warheads and then the
phase rugs and then Sams these are the
real okay so we have um
sour bright crawlers I think we've all
enjoyed these at one point in our lives
[Music]
I've never had any of these candies by
the way oh you liking them yeah that's
right this one's pretty sour
I just realized am I missing the Sour
Patch Kids on this
tearless I might have to add it real
quick oh my bad it's okay
a bee
seems like there's not a lot of
consistency it seems that some of us are
getting
sourversions
of the candies
I mean I think there is some variation
because it's usually the it's the dust
on it right that makes it sour almost
all of these candies are just like a
gummy candy with sour on the
outside so you're gonna get some
variants there
well at any rate
the gummy worms for me are a b depending
I really think I must see on that see
the trolleys here is that what we're on
yeah
the Crawlers
[Music]
D probably
and at this point Nila
it's time for Extreme Sour WarHeads and
these are the bane of my existence as
you guys know to my great shame I've
admit here on the show wait where did we
land with the trollies I'm sorry I think
there'd be Eli said c
you should be up there with the sour
strips I think not nice I agree I agree
with the c rating I must have got a
undusted sour strip you must have yeah
you know yeah or you guys agree with c
does everybody feel good about C I want
everyone to feel good about this you
know yeah it was important all right
well okay we're now moving on to
Warhead Extreme new Warheads now okay oh
really this one's Infamous no I've
admitted to my great shame something I
thought I would take to the Grave that I
used to wash them in the water
and then suck them it's a shame
I am humiliated that that did happen so
they're not your favorite candy I
apologize not my favorite candy but I am
going to do it today
I'm gonna do water free
the only water I'll use is the one in my
mouth baby I'm doing a yellow which
theoretically is the most sour which one
the yellow
um wait did you already do it no I
haven't popped it yet let's do it at the
same time the thing is here there's no
dusting on the Warhead this is like
advanced technology yeah yeah they're
Way Beyond the dust yeah you know that's
what it is yeah these people know what
they're doing
are you guys ready why does it lie I'm
ready I'm ready all right go ahead here
we go drop the bomb Oh
good
yeah that's shower that's good that
shower this was the
other one so far
oh my God
so good this is this is easy for me yeah
look at this brand new Warhead right
everything else feels like after
compared to this
it's on another level
um
it's like burning my tongue but that was
not as bad as the Rogue one was it uh
you're saying though Warhead wasn't as
bad as a rogue one no no I completely
disagree chump change
the rug one was pathetic dude zad L and
I say that is a massive phase fan like
that pains me to say oh those
now I got through that part
you good Ethan nothing in the middle
though surprisingly I thought it was
sweet in the middle sour candy supposed
to make you do
that was hard
that's if it tastes like unhealthy yeah
it's like maybe cancer causing it's good
for you man
oh my God that was I mean that's the S
chair right I mean of course how is it
not yeah Triple S do we have any left I
won't try that you know
yeah we have a bunch of warheads left
you want another one
yeah what color did you do
I try
pink that's probably the sweetest get
the yellow if you really I believe the
yellow is the sours now you really Gotta
Give It Up to the Warhead people
Buck FaZe rug these people 20 30 years
ago stepped up and said no
we are the kings of sour this is the
sour challenge
and guess what it probably costs 25
cents This I Swear
way less sour than phases candy
really I couldn't do that I agree with
candy what color I'm just chilling with
this blue one in my mouth and then did
it yeah yeah and all the reviews online
were like this candy sucks it's not sour
I feel like you have to try you have to
try it when we get there well we're here
we're here we've arrived
now to be fair to phase these have been
sitting
um but is there still quite um
they're still quite powdered because
they're gooey it kind of holds on to it
you know yeah
that one's got extra juice you want that
one oh my God this one has it too
all around all right so phase
rug that is anybody else want to do it
because there's three oh yeah you guys
don't have a big one yeah pass it around
okay Elena didn't try it yet oh let Lena
try it because she doesn't have one and
then I'd say either love or Olivia
because they're the ones that are saying
they didn't think they thought it was
pretty bad it was
again in the context of having all of
these other candies and see if it's as
sour as you remember look how sticky it
is
that is hanging on
at a 180 degrees all right I'm gonna do
it okay
I think you're meant to suck on them too
what the challenge says
okay I mean it's definitely he's
puckering pretty hard right now
it's so sour it's pretty bad
that is sour the most sour of what we
had so far I'm gonna use the most sour
really really
that that does not even compare to a
warhead I don't even like the flavor too
that's the worst part yeah part of the
problem is they're not good
you get like you get the victory at the
end it's sweet and it's yummy
right yeah you've been talking to Big
Game Ethan I feel like this was bad this
was sour and the sour didn't last long
right I haven't spoken yet I'm still
recovering how more sour than last time
so here's my here's my analysis
it hits you different
here's what I'll say
I know we're not judging flavor but it
tastes like and there's no reason
for that yeah at twenty dollars you
could have formulated something better
right that being said
on the sour level
I would I would frankly say that
I'd go a it's it is as here's the thing
it says sour
how's the Warhead but it feels like a
less clean sour
it's like cut with some with like baby
powder or something
[Laughter]
pure Colombian salad you know what I
mean yeah for sure it's like super
chemically yeah
so I mean it is very it is I think s
tier sour but yeah I think it's S I feel
but I don't know man it's just it sucks
to put it up there it feels bad just
based off of let's give it it is
[Music]
for me at least
up there though I don't need a
neutralizer though I mean the whole
their whole gimmick is like come give me
a break don't need to shoot my
mouth with a fire
extinguisher open chat are saying
because we drank no the neutralized kit
we did the neutralizer after it's just
sugar right before no we did it before
but I really don't think that those
makes much of a difference I think it's
what you guys drank it before yeah I was
like this thing like a little sip
sounding good I'll say this
it says sour as a warhead but I'm not
endorsing this product right again a
warhead costs 25 cents and it's better
in terms of taste it tastes good and
experience
FaZe rug this I still firmly would say
is a total scam he's selling you
tasting Warheads
five of them for 20 bucks no work stop
it dude stop it
all right now well now we come to the
the finale
wait are we just skipping over these
other ones I did everything in my bucket
you did the sour lemon drops I don't
have those here oh
well then that's there there you go
we're running one out to you right now
uh so there's two left I guess the sour
lemon drops and the AirHeads the air we
need the the like rainbow AirHeads too
the roof of my mouth
everybody else has those right everybody
drop you feel that it with my
mouth a lot too
it's bad I mean it's a lot it's
citrakastic that we're intentionally
putting in our mouths so
[Music]
okay so these are look like an English
treasure we've got the Great British
Great Britain flag here sour lemon drops
never had these oh thank you thank you
Zach
Lizzie in a box all right I'm I'm
popping one yep
oh they're big
it's also giving so it's got this nice
high quality powder like a warhead does
I haven't tried it yet though
oh that's not source of my life what's f
um
the English what the are you doing
over there dumbass you literally
put this on a boat and shipped it to us
this is the best export you've got I
gotta say
it's not a bad candy
yeah not sour
but we're on a mission today oh yeah I
understand but I'm not hating the lemon
drops
tiny little bit of me it's a tiny little
bit sour it's F though
unimportant announcement Buckingham
Palace has announced the death of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth II queen of
Queen Elizabeth would die again if she's
saw the rating on this candy
absolute tragedy
tragedy yeah
all right so there's one more there's
the extreme AirHeads I've never had
these either beautiful uh rainbow yeah
Pride
happy Pride everybody yes always Pride
[Music]
oh the flavor is good
not sour
CE a little bit
basically yeah aftertaste more sour than
I was expecting right chocolate mocha
but kind of ready
it was about the same as these red sour
belts I'd say
all right Sam so
[Music]
Sam has created her own concoction
she's taking it out of this is a safe
with uh metal gloves as we speak she's
wearing a mask a hazmat suit
I'm so excited I am so excited it's
beautiful just a black ball of death I
know I like that color Sam oh no it's
blue I like that though look at that
that's something you don't want to even
put in your body you know what I mean
oh my God I got you made this at home I
have high expectations for salmon
everything like this is going to kill me
now looking at the coding first of all
it's massive it looks like death this
looks like evil as
out of the package of this
this looks I have never made candy so I
don't know if the taste will 100 be
there but it is it is supposed to be
blue Raz with a sour lemon core have you
tried it I have tried it and it was hard
oh my god it feels like I barely touched
it feels like pins and needles on my
tongue
[Music]
so uh cheers to Sam cheers my dude does
it have a name
well I don't know I don't know what to
name it
we put the whole thing yeah
it is like real Sour so if it starts
very big hurting you can take it out of
here is this time to kill me
I make you your pants by the sound
of it fair enough don't make you
yourself
all right the black hole yeah seriously
that's actually not bad because a black
hole it like
pretty good
we gotta find a co-packer immediately
pure Co Packer email us this is we're
gonna get bring this to Market by the by
the end of the month
all right here we go guys we do account
God I don't want to do it I am scared I
don't want to put this in my mouth
should we do a countdown yeah yeah yeah
yeah it looks so scary up close yeah it
looks
dangerous all right everyone just pop it
in pop it in all right everybody go
three two one go
oh
my God that's poison
oh my God
that's a poison that's not candy
holy that's so sour
Jesus I'm still going dude you still
going oh my God I'm gonna pop it back in
I just I needed I mean for a second holy
dude this is straight up Sam I love
that oh my God
the flavors are like scrumptious here's
the thing that's a challenge yeah
whatever phase gun package is
that's a challenge what
[Music]
when I got through it
I got through it and I'm to the candy
layer and it's pretty good this is like
this is like a super ultra Mega
War you did it Sam okay
here you know what I'm gonna do Sam
because
yeah well I'm giving you the title this
used to be the WarHeads I've grown up
I've graduated now I want to taste the
candy okay and this is your honor now my
mouth I would say terrible don't bite it
because it is I bit it and it sticks to
your teeth bad so I'm gonna be careful
with that so we're washing it off in the
middle
there is there's like women in the
middle but I don't know
it's kind of is it
no
no shade but the candy itself isn't
mm-hmm oh yeah not the best I love the
sour layer I feel like this blue Raz
candy layer is a little too bitter that
was beautiful but I'm curious to get to
the middle so I'm gonna
I'm gonna crack it smell bad my mouth
still tastes terrible oh my God look at
your tongue
oh yeah
is this safe to eat
your dog
I'm taking it here so you can see it on
the screen here
oh my God wait that's a fun element
Sam this might be unsafe for human
consumption no it's fine
am I like gums are itching the FDA is
gonna have to clear this wow
that was an experience well done I mean
you you actually knocked out yeah
I don't know how you did that one's here
now oh my God it's the best day ever I'm
actually I am actually serious that I
think that would make a good product
yeah I agree it's certainly more of a
challenge in the rug yeah this is a real
challenge we need like the H3 sour
challenge this is on the level of like
the spicy chip challenge I think so yeah
is there
is there actual regulation about how
much like citric acid and you can
have in a candy that's what I might have
actually gone beyond the legal threshold
here that's what I wonder but probably
there is there is that's what Warhead is
at
oh really did you surpass the limit
um only a little but I did follow I
Loosely followed a recipe and the people
who made it had a very similar reaction
I'm gonna have renal films like which is
I'm sure we'll all be fine but to bring
that to Market might actually but we'd
have to do the formula right yeah tweak
the formula when I think about how spicy
the spicy chip is versus like how sour I
feel like
is unregulated
every time regulated I mean they sell
that chip if they sell that chip yeah I
mean that's looking why are they hating
on sour I don't know the FDA is like if
you eat uh over this level it does pose
a risk of bodily harm and uh also
um don't eat this if you're pregnant
okay I reading because
um
to do with there's a large market for
kids with candy
yeah not like spicy I wonder if we
Market it for adults if that would uh
we'll look into it I'm gonna look into
it this is definitely for adults you
know what FDA lawyer
all right okay start talking shop
you know what I mean co-packers we are
putting this in we're gonna have QR
codes there's a chance that one of you
guys is gonna win like I think like I
don't know 50
000. like one of you guys just keeps
scanning them don't even eat the candy
just scan the code promise it'll be
worth it
I'm saying something about acid eating
away your gums in your mouth yeah it
does taste like poison to be honest when
I put it you're just putting acid in
your mouth you know my tongue's
up I do mine too it's too fast
[Laughter]
so safe before I did anything you did
how did can I ask how did you do that
yeah
the whole thing
so it's just corn syrup sugar
and water pretty much and you have to
heat it to a certain temperature to get
that like hard crack then you miss mix
in the citric acid you put it into the
mold
so I just did that three times basically
and then I put them together and then I
rolled it in the oil and citric
wow okay what about the sour coating
that I'm interested in it's it's citric
acid it's just citric acid yeah so you
just dumped a lot on well I I tossed it
in coconut oil so the citric acid would
stick a lot of people use citric and
malic acid that's what Warhead does okay
yeah I didn't have access to food grade
like malic acid so we'll get through
that yeah no worries whatever malic acid
whatever you need to do a lab like
underground yep
pure 99.9 percent
all right that was fun I gotta say
congratulations fam took it down took
down the whole candy industry really and
overall pretty disappointed by the sour
showing I'd say on the whole although I
guess they're meant to be enjoyed yeah
you know but even the WarHeads I thought
was like it's a good pretty good candy
they really did something special with
this I agree excellent and the fact that
it is is spicy or spicy as sour as it is
but then you're you're rewarded with
such a delightful little it's so nice so
yeah it's just a perfect balance
and it comes and saves you just when you
need it yep yep
very good
very exciting there it is
we've come to a conclusion folks we're
doing science out here at the H3 podcast
boots on the ground like nobody else in
the biz
meanwhile
as the the Taco Bell comes out
um
Kim Kardashian's daughter
that's awesome
okay that's North I guess yeah
she hit that she says stinky she hit
that good
wow
I don't think we should I just feel bad
I feel weird using a kid's sound yeah I
agree
you know he's kind of a superstar
clearly Kim doesn't but yeah
you know
and there's no oh yeah all right moving
on what do we got here
as we wait for I want to wait till
everybody's seated to talk about the xqc
thing because he's making threats
against me
but lizzo responded we actually talked a
great length about the lizzo lawsuit
yeah I I was listening to that part of
the show and so
you know I was watching um
uh
our lawyer friend
Emily Emily yeah Emily Baker I was
watching Emily Baker read the complaint
yeah yeah and she I she really agreed
with me and a lot of the stuff didn't
seem like
either that bad or actionable okay for
example
one of the complaints is that she was
forced to do a nude photo shoot that was
on her reality show like the environment
was that's the environment on the shows
that you do that stuff you know what I
mean like it's the expectation when
you're there
and so the way that she framed that
seems a little like missing the context
yeah I thought a lot of it was
I don't know I I I anyway here's what
lizzo said these fat uh these last few
days have been gut-wrenchingly difficult
and overwhelmingly disappointing my work
ethic morals and respectfulness have
been questioned my character has been
criticized
usually I choose not to respond to false
allegation but these are as unbelievable
as they sound and too outrageous not to
be addressed
these sensationalized stories are coming
from former employees who have already
publicly admitted that they were told
their behavior on tour was inappropriate
and unprofessional that's it
no there is more that's not it
as an artist I've always been very
passionate about what I do I take my
music and performance seriously because
at the end of the day I only want to put
out the best art that represents me and
my fans
with passion comes hard work and high
standards sometimes I have to make hard
decisions but it's never my intention to
make anyone feel uncomfortable or like
they aren't valued as an important part
of the team
as I am not here to be looked at as a
victim but I also know that I am not the
villain that people in the media have
portrayed me to be these last few days
I'm very open with my sexuality and
express myself but I cannot accept or
allow people to use that openness to
make me out to be something I'm not
there's nothing I take more seriously
than the respect we deserve as women in
the world I know what it feels like to
be body shamed on a daily basis and
would absolutely never criticize or
terminate employee because of the way
and again I kind of gotta
I I believe her on the weight thing
because the proof of the fact shaming
was just that she said
you need to try harder or something I
don't remember but it was something like
that
innocuous
that they weren't committed or yeah
you're not committed enough that's it uh
I'm hurt but I will not let the work
I've done in this world be overshadowed
by this I want to thank everyone who has
reached out in support to lift me up
during this difficult time and and
surprisingly she hasn't yet put out the
flute apology
which is a shame
what do you think I mean it's pretty
standard I feel like it's really hard to
tell I don't know enough about yeah I
don't know about about the situation and
this could easily be like her just
denying everything even though it did
happen so I don't know I I really don't
know right yeah it's not very
Illuminating
um one thing I I heard uh I saw a crisis
manager raiding this response and she
says it's on YouTube I don't know I get
weird
weird sidebar action okay but she said
something really interesting she says
it's smart that she did it in Instagram
stories because there's no comments just
Instagram stories and then what gets
passed around is just this image of the
text yeah and there's no comments you
know it's just talking mad and you
know frankly influencing people's
opinion
yeah I never even thought about that but
that is pretty clever
so
oh Beyonce though left lizzo's name
out
no she lizzo posted that as a grid post
there are comments for that one they did
post this yeah here
wait what
lizzo posted that permanently on her
Instagram not oh yeah hello I guess that
woman was wrong not much of a crisis man
I'm gonna need a crisis manager after
making a mistake like that
okay
also she has a comments on so
um there were also like I was seeing
going around Twitter like some of the
celebrities who had liked it
let me see if I can find it uh it seems
like she didn't address everything
though right because what were the other
allegations because he's only talking
about the fat shaming and the the sex
stuff which is what was the fat shaming
and then like the nude photos and then
the ball the stripping stuff where they
she like made she forced not forced her
she influenced her to touch a naked
stripper stuff like that there's the
banana being shot out the which
was my favorite standout
apparently they went to a strip club
where this this stripper was shooting
objects from her vagina
including a banana okay and uh what was
the other object a dildo a dildo oh a
dil I'm not a banana a dildo no it was
Bull she was shooting a dildo out which
is pretty impressive you know
thank you yeah this is her this is the
lady
who responds that was a tick though
thank you let's break down team lizzo's
response from wait a crisis community
did you put it up on the screen oh your
screen froze yeah it is
but definitely very loyary so
I don't think it's going to do much of
anything for anyone
but the top comments are all pretty
brutal
top comment is saying I'm open with my
sexual sexualities I've waited a nice
sexual assault claim that statement was
I'm sorry okay I think we're up she said
something and nothing at the same time
nice lowering open my sexuality well
that's a really cute way to dismiss
sexual assault yeah
yeah I don't think she was accused of
sexual assault
right I don't think so
it was harassment yeah harassment one of
the top comments says
she's sexually assaulted this is the way
that these things get Amplified sorry
about this awful statement put out
diminishing the victim's claims while
also Shifting the blame to the victim no
owning no explaining no good promises
it's just smoke and mirrors empty and
Hollow I'm just beyond disappointed
It's Tricky man even if she's like
clearly she thinks she's fully innocent
she did nothing wrong
well reply be you know it's a sign that
this is bad though there's no like
there's no level at all of like
okay maybe I did some right
like giving a little bit of something
like
um
I appreciate this being brought up you
know and I'm gonna do better kind of
thing like I'm I'm gonna learn for my
mistake I don't know like some kind of
like at least acknowledge that they're
that they felt that way they felt that
way yeah and also
people outside of your your dance troop
felt that way her ex creative director
and other people outside has said that
she's super rude and mean to work with
oh yeah I like
saying just straight out that it's false
and that's it is a little bit like
I agree it's not too black and white
hold on someone says She's accused of
assault how
oh they're false imprisonment
well that's not sexual assault that was
that was just a good old uh false
imprisonment
right
so here's Beyonce apparently leaving her
out brutal
skips over a name during Queens remix
performance
is this all the problems my laptop
oh
all right bear with us here guys
I heard nothing by the way from this
clip
foreign
ly it's in there somewhere
that she did not say lizzo
oh my God Olivia you went to the Taylor
Swift show I did I did it was so good it
turned in too what's up Taylor did too
oh my God Hey Taylor is you Swifty
yeah kind of I'm Swifty I live for it
anything whatever you guys I love her
nobody speaks to me the way she does so
how was the show tell us about it it was
so good it was so nostalgic the amount
of lyrics that my brain knew and I
didn't know that they knew
impeccable I've never felt the way I
felt when she's saying that he nailed
down and pulled out a ring and said in
love story I lost my damn mind it was so
good it was so caught up in the moment
I went with my sister my sister's like
the Swifty of the fam that's exactly
what um Taylor described she's like I'm
not exactly a Swifty but I knew all the
lyrics so yeah it like took me over I
was also yeah I was having the time in
my life
um how were your seeds
they were good yeah we were up off
quite like super close but it was good
I've heard so much about her shows being
like impossible to get tickets crazy
expensive
and all this
yeah but uh someone somewhere they got
in
yeah you got tickets we did can I eat
this yeah honestly it's like
she's so successful
and I kind of feel like sometimes people
feel like they want to hate but like
technically what is there to hate I
don't know just have fun dance a little
bit maybe
Shake It Off shake it off that speaks to
me that song specifically yeah we have
media from it
oh yes we do have media from it so um
but what was she like was there a lot
going on on stage was there um yeah it
was very theatrical she um dances like a
witch I thought it was very funny like
all of her moves are like
um I was so surprised by the consistency
of her voice through the whole show
because I've never really thought about
her as like super vocally trained or
anything but the way that the strength
of her voice carried her through the
show was crazy and let me ask you
I've been to a lot of shows with pop
singers they sing over their track would
you be doing that or was it just her
um I assumed that she was probably
singing over a track but you could tell
like when that was real and when it
wasn't you know yeah
apparently the merch line had a three
hour wait
a day before Oh
they were selling merch the day before
oh wow that's the way to do it wow damn
these people know how to get paid
wait where are the people
um are the people all the way on the
other side of the river of the lake that
is absolutely
insane wow wow
did you stand in that line Olivia
I did not
um they uh separated I don't know if
they changed it like it between the two
days but every floor had like three
different merch booths so it the the
lines were split up
listen to this she played 45 songs the
show was three and a half hours
that's pretty that's that's long that's
crazy that is crazy
and she's doing six nights at this uh
venue dude you got it they're all like
three I mean yeah you get like I'm not a
fan of her music You Gotta Give it up
for that that's that's pure fan love
right there exactly that's crazy 45
songs dude that's like all of them well
you know I was obviously so grateful to
have been there there were Whispers
Selena Gomez was gonna come out didn't
happen it didn't happen which I'm
obviously it's okay I just she was also
posting during the show I was like
checking her Instagram because she was
posting story after Story like throwback
photos and I was like she's trying to
throw this up and then she never came
out but it's fine was there any uh guest
singers there were no guests for my name
but the entire the entire night was like
a beautiful surprise you know every
single song I was surprised and happy we
got videos and photos
from Olivia
oh my god dude how many people are in
there whoa
a lot of people so five Stadium how does
that hold crazy uh I believe
let's see
wow 70k
70 000. yeah but it looks like they
would have to kill
you know about a fifth of that
behind the stage well they're also on
the ground dude there's people behind
the stage too
they're people they're sitting there
yeah I guess you're right it does look
like
that's some sad boy yeah I guess
they're just staring at the back of a TV
Taylor Swift was performing the same
night as the crater Clash 2 in the same
area and so it made the ticket prices
super expensive there was like no hotels
available traffic was insane because of
Taylor she was actually a mayor for the
day of Tampa dude she straight up runs
her own ecosystem you run the down now
I think it's super cool that she does
such a good long show though yeah no
that's that's awesome
so what do you think her tickets run on
average because I know it's
it's really expensive right yeah I think
yeah
average ticket price what is it like 400
maybe maybe less 300 average ticket
price
I'm curious what she's pulling in per
night
wait is this Insider said this is
probably because of all of the resale
not face value but the average Swifty
paid about thirteen hundred dollars to
attend there
oh but that incl okay they're saying
that includes like the merch that they
buy there and everything that still
means the ticket okay a thousand I'll
say a thousand well so she's doing seven
million a night that's nuts what and
she's doing how many shows in La five
six whoa that's 56 million dude
she just gave her bus drivers like a big
bonus I did that's awesome she's kind of
the best she sounds like the best she
put aside like 40 million as a tip for
all everyone working the show
well look it it looks Bloomberg's
reporting she's making 13 million a
night whoa that's probably her cut after
yeah I guess I don't know
30 million a night that's ticket sales
of more than 13 million a night on the
road that's just ticket sales think
about the merch too
much is wow much more than ticket sales
with this many people I don't know if
it's more or less but it but it it's a
lot I'm sure significant so okay
significantly more than 13 million
Taylor Swift everybody damn it's
impressive
uh Taylor Swift apparently caused a 2.3
earthquake during her Show in Seattle it
showed up on the uh on this Richter
scale
here it is
uh Taylor Swift fans Shake It Off
causing record-breaking seismic activity
during a Seattle show
there she is man she's tipping the meter
kind of scary to be honest
like you're in the stadium
I I thought about that too man oh my God
giant sinkhole underneath bye bye
so there it is the power of swifties
can I ask you what was the uh gender
spread of the people you saw there hmm
majority female problem was it like vast
or somewhat balanced
somewhat balanced short I mean like
maybe one fourth to three-fourths so
like not necessarily bounce but what
you'd what I imagined
nice she just oh yeah she gave 55
million to uh
to the crew including a hundred thousand
dollar bonus for her tour truck drivers
that's
I love that dude even if you don't like
her music you got to give it up yeah
this is all good that I'm hearing
all good things
you know
well we stand uh we stand uh a queen yes
all right now everyone's here I could
talk about this xqc
so
yesterday me and Hassan were talking
about the react channels that just mean
and specifically xqc who you know
I open a few of his videos and he he
literally would sit there for two
minutes from the beginning without
saying a word about it one of those and
then his commentary would be like he
would start talking and it's not even
related to the video got it the problem
with what he does when where does he do
it on rumble or whatever uh okay kick
he's all in twitch twitch but then he
recently got a big fat deal with
characters hey what's up Felix oh 100
million yeah right yes
so here's the here's the issue
doing it on Twitch is a separate
conversation if that if that's like fair
use or if that's a problem for the
copyright holders whatever
the problem here is he Clips out in
its entirety
unedited and puts it on his YouTube
channel
it's absolutely nuts and I'll show you
an example
um
I'll just click this one
watch this chat guys I'm thinking
chat
this actually might make you aware
be careful
it's gonna make you aware install a
dating app and try their luck I'm gonna
make you aware tries to set up the
perfect profile a nice front picture
a group picture to make it seem like he
has friends this is a main pole picture
in Paris to make it seem like it's
cultured
at a picture climbing mountains to make
it seem like he's adventurous
after some hard work the profile is
ready
the woman doesn't feel safe sharing a
lot of personal information so she
chooses the first picture she can find
and she's ready to go 40 minutes
I hope for the best
[Music]
yeah at the end of the day when the
woman checks her phone her light counter
is full practically every profile she
likes 55 seconds
soon she's overwhelmed by the amount of
matches and messages on her that's one
minute for the man it's a different
story so far he has only received a
couple of likes okay zero match okay
here we go he becomes frustrated whoa
okay
so I don't think that counts as common
what did he say
he said whoa
[Music]
so I think if you're presenting this to
a judge you probably wouldn't include
that as commentary but we have several
people on the staff that speak xqc would
anybody here to interpret that because I
I also could not really I think you said
that's right Intel base a little bit uh
he said it's in cell bait insults a
little bit got it okay okay wow right
okay play it again now that we know what
it is back it up
likes okay zero matches he becomes
frustrated whoa okay
there's so much he said Intel he
definitely said Intel how did you hear
that bro what the book is that it just
is that something we're we're not young
enough to know about I want to say Intel
bait
no I know what he means by that Intel
Bay he means I think he means yeah he
means in cell but you can't say in cell
on Twitch
so
yeah I found that out the hard way I
called into fousey stream I didn't say
like five times oops my bad that is you
can say in Seoul you can't just call
someone and so oh yeah but Intel is just
kind of like a clever way around that I
mean that'd be my guys
so so deep at this point I don't even
know how people watch this but okay
that's not my thing
I can say I would rather watch his
reaction than the original video but
that but it's still the plan that helps
your argument yeah because he's not
transforming you but it's still
makes people want to watch it because
it's just something he's literally
supplanting the original video yeah
you know people come here to watch this
video not to watch xqc react right
because he's not doing anything yeah no
it just adds like the shadow a little
bit I'm not saying it's transformative
it just adds for me to watch it hey I
got it but yeah
here's a minute ten he said like one
sentence setting up a nice profile after
all why can't he get any matches he's
like at least yeah to answer that
question you need to understand the
numbers he's ugly as he's ugly as
okay ugly as man I don't think
that counts as commentary either
who's he talking about
another dating profile video
it's just not enough
I made a simulation of a dating app with
1000 dummies to try to understand why
men get so few matches
dating apps can yo because they gotta
compete guys guys you guys I feel like
this is just like
Chad can you just break it break this
down just evolutionary like it's just
like normal like like animal type
dude he's like you gotta compete bruh
why do you think some birds look really
nice and do all these tricks and add all
these these feathers that are all these
colors and they're the men and when the
women it's just a brown bird
because the benefit of appeal the best
and do all these so okay I mean I guess
it is fine this counts as commentary
yeah yeah this one part is all fine so
it took him about two minutes
you know
but if I went through this anyway
whatever he does this right
and so we were talking about it I said
he's a Content thief because I mean a
lot of his stuff he just sits there and
doesn't talk and doesn't care
about
fair use she doesn't care about it and
analyzing it doesn't care about the
people whose content he's stealing those
eggshells who is making the eggshells
that he has to break
the omelets he has to cook
so here so he reacted in here here's
what he said
which it doesn't it doesn't load
kick.com crushing it this didn't look
for me either
lovekick.com kick
okay kick so hopefully they're not all
like that
he said apparently
he says Ethan and Son aren't consistent
picking and choosing one to make a legal
argument versus a moral argument I'd
love to see
what he said
kick here he is when he says he's going
to sue me by the way for saying he's a
Content Thief which got my attention
okay I don't want to I don't know
I'm sorry okay listen listen
if I flex on that ass
I swear I'm not doing it by the username
and make you look like a they're a
bunch of when people act like
some I had to call them out and
I'm sorry about that okay so I'm looking
Dennis one time
thank you
them
they can actually suck it okay
this whole thing of theft he's doing
theft that goes against your point
directly instantly okay you are an idiot
freaking brain that and you know he
didn't say allegedly he didn't say he
literally called me a a thief and steal
her right on the broadcast which
to be honest isn't really a good look
for me and maybe maybe it's not a good
look for you bro that's why I said it
you know you are a content if you know
okay it cuts out here so I saw he was
alluding to I don't know why it doesn't
the whole thing right on the
broadcast which to be honest isn't
really a good book for me and maybe
maybe hey
is there a longer clip anyway he says
he's he it's defamation essentially oh
which I thought was pretty funny
um then we ended up tweeting each other
about it oh really yeah just a little
bit just because like when I saw that I
got a little
I got a little heated up I guess wound
up I don't know I wasn't heated it's
just funny when people I don't think he
knows
that
doing dumb lawsuits is my is like
literally my favorite hobby
I'd like to say publicly that xuc is a
Content thief and if you think that is
defamation please sue me
destroying morons in court is my
favorite hobby and if you want me to
explain why your content Thief I'm happy
to chat with you anytime actually
interestingly I think he's going to call
in on Monday okay
so
maybe we'll get somewhere
probably not though
but we'll we'll talk
and then here well this was after I saw
this too where he just mimics my
Tourette's instead of actually
addressing what we're saying I showed
this already I don't like that on
YouTube it is most likely from a fan
channel that took a straight Vaude rip
and posted it on YouTube and is
monetizing it themselves it's not it's
not touching me in any capacity
and can I be honest with you there will
be a time in my opinion there will be
some
legal Hammer that will come down on
streamers and there will be a time no
chat no chat no chat there will be a
time where people don't even use cars
anymore dude they used to be people
we're gonna start flying do you know
chat there's a Time chat
check there's a Time chat where people
are going to be teleporting dude oh
I can't even understand they literally
he sucks dude he just sucks you know
he's a douche
how do you does he do stuff like this
usually love
sure like low like low blows like that
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he doesn't really care
right
uh here is a DM he sent me he said
oh yeah he messaged me first he said
debate me old guy
Jesus
is he age
27. huh
that young dude
a little older you know I mean you're
around the bend there buddy
you're pushing 30. you're pushing 30 Bud
for sure you still got bleach tips
okay no I'm kidding yeah we love bleach
dip folks out here
we respect the bleach tips
um
oh wait there was more
debate me I said sure I wanted to do
today but I realized we had the sour
thing anyway we talked more and we
worked it out to Monday
it was nice in the DMS okay yeah no
problem
here is
what you're looking this video shows xqc
reacting to my video
he leaves room five seconds into the
video and returns 10 minutes later
making a mockery out of the fact that he
is not reacting I mean dude you should
sue him like that's an easy win
that's just straight up content theft
what you're looking at is considered
them and he says he gets permission but
here's one of the guys whose videos he
stole most densely populated place that
ever existed on on an area of just 6.5
Acres or four football fields dozens of
individual buildings have merged into
all right cool nice bro
it's rewind time to allowed various work
do not pose this to YouTube for the lack
of react to the lack of react again
that's weird
well I guess I was saying he didn't want
to post that on YouTube so I don't know
it's kind of edge case
I think this is this is a very rare
copper alloy right there Chad somebody
chat pull a chat review of this city I
mean the guy's right he's making a
mockery of it he's still stealing his
content it's a separate conversation I
think but even if he sued him I think on
Twitch this is also would be
content theft but my my laptop's not
working
yeah I'll work on fixing that
me me and Hassan talked a lot about it
on
Thursday so that's what that is
well anyway it's 4 30 anyway maybe we
should wrap it
we're having some tech issues
I think it might have been related to
the power out maybe probably oh
let's
hmm
all right well I think something might
have blown up
he blew it
so guys thank you everybody I think
we'll just wrap it up in the interest 4
30.
thank you guys so much
have a great weekend thank you for being
here
and uh
listen
it's an H3 podcast
not winning the streamies this year
hey
this is some rainy weather out here in
L.A tell you that
dude we got a big weekend ahead I can't
wait to talk about it on Monday
can't wait really do we I'll type it out
oh you do have a big weekend I know
somebody does what's the weather this
weekend
uh
I'm not saying nothing don't say it
don't read it out loud
it's a rainy day out here in Los Angeles
is it gonna rain or something yeah it's
a rainy day
why can't we talk about it what the hell
wait what's happening I thought it was
under the Freshman we're allowed to talk
about it until oh
so Mom's the Word I guess Mom's a word
yeah on Monday something big is
happening I mean you're revolutionary
you could say what it is without saying
what it is right uh no because yeah I
think I'll just say I'm going to Arizona
this weekend all right fine there it is
going to Arizona baby's from Arizona Los
Angeles 115 degrees just consider it a
big tease for Monday
very cool will be announced on Monday
well get your eyes peeled everywhere
have a good good weekend we love you
thanks for being here another week
I think she broadcast
we will be back on Monday
for another week of mediocre shows
hopefully better than this week though
that's always the goal
all right guys
see you next time thanks for watching
have a good weekend
[Music]
thank you